à d'urgence on est en train de détruire
la biodiversité s'accélère la gestation
ça s'accélère de manière exponentielle
ça veut dire que chaque minute l'écart
entre ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on devrait
faire augmenter
oui donc c'est de plus en plus graves
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités tenus à bonne distance
et nos reporters sur le terrain
l'actualité toujours dominé par la crise
du corps ou des virus en france et dans
le monde voici les titres hausse
significative des salaires et
changements dont le quotidien à
l'hôpital dans les tout prochains mois
déclaration d'edouard philippe qui vient
d'ouvrir le ségur de la santé une
visioconférence avec 300 acteurs du
milieu hospitalier pour répondre aux
préoccupations des soignants très
éprouvé par la crise coronavirus l'om et
suspend temporairement les essais
cliniques avec l'hydro xi chloroquine
par sécurité annonce ce soir trois jours
après la publication dans la revue
scientifique the lancet d'une étude qui
pointe non seulement l'inefficacité de
ce médicament contre locaux vides 19
mais aussi son caractère potentiellement
dangereux pour la santé
foireuse c'est ainsi que didier rahout a
qualifié sur sa chaîne youtube ses
conclusions et si un candidat outsider
émerger
pour la présidentielle de 2000 22
emmanuel macron a récemment multiplié
les contacts avec des personnalités
dites aux populistes selon nos confrères
du monde il craindrait en réalité
l'émergence d'une personnalité anti
système
le chômage partiel à partir du 1er juin
l'état n'assurera plus la prise en
charge complète de ce dispositif les
salariés eux ne perdront rien ce sont
les employeurs qui vont devoir payer un
peu plus explique bruno le maire les
entreprises assumeront 15% du coût des
1er juin a précisé la ministre du
travail pour les secteurs qui ne
reprendront pas leur activité à cette
date l'intégralité du chômage partiel
sera maintenu
[Musique]
coup d'envoi du ségur de la santé après
plus de deux mois de crise sanitaire
l'exécutif et 300 personnalités du monde
hospitalier se met au chevet d'un milieu
professionnel en difficulté rémunération
organisation est temps de travail au
menu les précisions avec notre reporter
thomas bonnin le premier ministre a
ouvert officiellement ce ségur de la
santé en promettant du changement dans
le quotidien des personnels hospitaliers
certain niveau de rémunération ne sont
pas à la hauteur de l'engagement voilà
pour une des déclarations du premier
ministre qui a en quelque sorte poser
les bases de réflexion pour cette
concertation qui sont qui s'ouvre donc
aujourd'hui parmi ces pistes de
réflexion il ya la question de la
reconnaissance des soignants le premier
ministre promet une revalorisation
significative des salaires le temps de
travail la question du temps de travail
n'est pas une question taboue a
également a déclaré edouard philippe
parmi les autres pistes avancées par le
premier ministre celle de
l'investissement et du financement des
hôpitaux ou encore une nouvelle
organisation du système de santé au
niveau territorial voilà qui devrait
servir de point de départ pour cette
discussion qui réunit 300 participants
au tour du ministre de la santé et du
premier ministre
de leur côté le personnel soignant
attend des actes concrets un certain
nombre d'entre eux étaient présents à
quelques mètres du ministère de la santé
pour faire entendre leurs revendications
des revendications qu'ils portent
parfois depuis des années je propose de
les écouter étant donné que tu as quand
même pas mal de temps déjà qu'on demande
et que
ne serait-ce que là avec le
sous-effectif les soi-disant 300
milliards que monsieur macron devait
donner pour le corps hospitalier qui
l'heure rien donné
on est tous plus tôt on attend de voir
on attend de voir un moment donné il
faut qu'ils embauchent aussi et donc
pour embaucher il va falloir augmenter
les grilles salariales c'est clair parce
que ça fait déjà des années et des
années qu'on n'arrive pas à embaucher
il nous manque 800 900 infirmière sur la
paix sont que ça c'est inadmissible
du fait de salaires trop bas tout
simplement les ou appart ou et ne
viennent pas ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose oui c'est quand même
100 milles plus de 100000 dit qu'on
était fermé depuis 15 ans et ça c'est
pas normal et donc on l'a vu là
justement sur la gestion de la crise où
il nous a manqué des lits il a fallu
rouvrir des services qui étaient fermés
mais quand il est avec une grosse grosse
vétusté est donc là il a fallu rouvrir
ça et faire dans l'urgence on l'a fait
il ya pas de souci c'est notre job c'est
ce que je dis on ne rebondisse vous êtes
des héros et non on n'est pas des héros
enfin moi je me considère pas comme un
héros
je suis on est payé pour faire un job on
a fait notre job m'a lancé les
conditions qu'on l'a fait qu'ils sont
complètement déplorable et c'est pour ça
aussi qui on est là faut pas qu'ils nous
le gouvernement attendus sur des
réponses concrètes donc par le personnel
hospitalier la concertation de ce ségur
de la santé devrait durer entre sept et
huit semaines
à l'issue de ces discussions un plan
devrait être présenté par le
gouvernement et on verra à ce moment là
s'il répond aux attentes du personnel
hospitalier particulièrement éprouvés
par la crise du col et 19 et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec
stéphane dauger et chef du service de
réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
robert debré bonsoir ses fans danger
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france edouard philippe qui promet donc
un que le quotidien des personnels
soignant à l'hôpital changerait dans les
tout prochains mois ça laisse présager
des changements concrets pour vous la
crise du commis de rois au moins servi à
cela
bonsoir on voit pas les choses vraiment
comme ça comme vous le savez ça fait
très longtemps qu'on crie que l'hôpital
public ne fonctionnent plus correctement
en tous les cas n'est plus en adéquation
avec les besoins de la population
je pense que ça a mis la loupe
grossissante sur les difficultés qu'on a
réussi à surmonter mais qui reste majeur
donc pour l'instant on va plus pouvoir
se payer de mots c'est pour ça qu'on a
sorti un manifeste qu'on a travaillé
qu'on a fait des propositions c'est
quasiment plus de 50 pages qui ont été
écrites par de nombreux professionnels
des directeurs des économistes pour aria
sur la table de négociation avec des
propositions
il nous faut des gestes forts tout de
suite pour qu'après on puisse se mettre
au travail
si ce même c'est très très court pour
réformer l'hôpital des systèmes de santé
j'ai un peu de doute mais en tous les
cas le collectif inter hôpitaux le
collectif inter urgence moi je parle
pour le cih et très motivé et a envie
que ça avance donc nous avons fait des
propositions
nous voulons des gestes forts tout de
suite et après nous sommes au travail
avec l'ensemble des partenaires
on en a évidemment parlé plusieurs fois
mais il faut le répéter effectivement la
veille de l'ouverture de ce secteur de
la santé vous dites des gestes forts
tout de suite
quels sont vos archives si je peux me
permettre de m'exprimer ainsi aux archi
priorité
elles sont très simples alors d'abord
nous sommes un mouvement qui réunit
toutes sortes de professionnels de
l'hôpital public et en plus des usagers
qui ont créé ce mouvement il ya
maintenant plusieurs mois à la suite du
séisme
vous rappelez au début de l'automne
l'année dernière pour lequel ont été
votées des principales motion d'urgence
il était hors de question de l'échangé
depuis les et derniers événements la
première revendication très forte c'est
effectivement une augmentation salariale
est un geste fort tout de suite avant la
mise en route de négociations par
branches en fonction des statuts ça ce
sont nos collègues des syndicats qui les
porteront mais on veut un geste tout de
suite de reconnaissance des personnels
la deuxième c'est un moratoire immédiat
sur l'arrêt des fermetures de lits je
pense que là aussi le coville a
parfaitement démontré on a manqué de vie
dans certaines régions faute
d'organisation il faut arrêter de fermer
des lits redonner la main aux régions et
aux territoires pour réfléchir à quel
endroit on peut en ré ouvrir en ré
ouvrir plus voir arrêter d'en ouvrir
dans certains autres ça ça doit être une
décision locale
en tous les cas prises avec l'ensemble
des personnels et puis il faut troisième
geste fort sur la gouvernance qu'on n'a
jamais réussi à obtenir pour une seule
raison c'est que le gouvernement ne
voulait pas investir dans l'hôpital
public à la hauteur des besoins
s'il décide de le faire on va regarder
qu'il donne aussi la main au personnel
et aux usagers pour arriver réellement à
gouverner correctement l'hôpital public
un parmi les gestes forts parmi les
premiers que vous ne citiez on imagine
qu'il y à là la hausse des salaires pour
se hisser dans la moyenne nationale est
ce que vous avez un chiffre à nous
annoncer
vous avancez dans vos souhaits
écoutez le chiffre qu'on nous pour
lequel on avait voté et qui est là et
qui ne tombe pas du ciel qui correspond
pour en tous les cas des personnels
paramédicaux à la mise à niveau suite au
gel du point d'indicé durant dix ans
c'est 300 euros par mois net pour les
personnels paramédicaux ça encore c'est
une revendication qui a été voté par
l'ensemble des professionnels du
collectif
nous voulons un geste fort et nous
sommes prêts à prêt à réfléchir à la
mise en route des négociations et
l'évolution salariale mais il faut un
geste fort ce chiffre peut servir de
référence il correspond au manque à
gagner des personnels et en plus les
remets exactement dans la médiane où la
moyenne des salaires des postes
équivalents en europe cinq absents
annoncé par edouard philippe la
reconnaissance pour nos soignants
l'investissement massif l'agilité
retrouver l'organisation territoriale et
enfin la modernisation par le numérique
est ce que selon vous ces axes vont dans
le bon sens
oh je pense que ce sont des gros groupes
de travail qui sont tout à fait
intéressant et qui peuvent tout à fait
permettre d'en savoir plus et d'avancer
correctement
il n'empêche que il faut voir ce qu'on
va pouvoir il m je suis un peu inquiet
des seuls six semaines de travail pour
arriver à un résultat
donc les titres des groupes de travail
me paraissait satisfaisant
cela peut correspondre à des points très
importants pour refonder l'hôpital
public les maîtres mots pour nous c'est
la présence des usagers et la présence
de tous les personnels dans les
décisions et la nécessité de renforcer à
la fois les lits et le nombre de
personnels correctement pays
donc si ces choses là sont prises en
compte dans les jours qui viennent
qu'on ressent que tout de suite nous
sommes très le gouvernement est prêt à
faire ces efforts là et bien là
discussion va continuer et a priori ces
cinq groupes de travail
personnellement en tous les cas je n'ai
pas encore discuté avec des collègues
peuvent permettre l'avancée il faut que
la volonté soit très clair en face nous
la volonté nous l'avons eu
nous avons posé sur la table un
manifeste avec un très grand nombre de
points de propositions de plus de 50
pages qui peut tout à fait servir de
base à une réflexion forte
stéphane augé la dette des hôpitaux
publics français attend aujourd'hui près
de 30 milliards d'euros c'est évidemment
énorme est ce que dans ce travail vous
avez tenu compte justement de cette
dette pour aller vers une refonte totale
du système et et entêtant faire se peut
de réduire des dépenses lourdes des
hôpitaux publics
je crois que je vous avais déjà répondu
comme ça il ya quelques mois je ne suis
pas économiste de la santé bien
évidemment des collègues ont travaillé
sur ce sujet il est difficile des pistes
avaient été déjà abordé par le
gouvernement comme entre autres le
rachat de la dette par le gouvernement
pour limiter les frais de la dette
il est évident qu'il va falloir investir
mais encore une fois monsieur le
président de la république l'a dit à
mulhouse
très clairement a employé des mots très
forts auxquels les soignants se sont
attachés très clairement ils les
répètent dans nos services dans nos
hôpitaux
donc oui il va falloir investir ça veut
dire trouver de l'argent j'aurais envie
de dire toujours une seule chose à son
endroit là quel est le marqueur qu'on
regarde pour comparer les résultats aux
investissements fourni et ses marqueurs
il existe dans l'organisation mondiale
de la santé ou ailleurs c'est la santé
de la population c'est le vieillissement
en bonne santé c'est moi je suis
pédiatre l'évolution et la prise en
compte des maladies chroniques
nous sommes très très loin des standards
internationaux aujourd'hui alors que
nous étions les premiers il ya encore
quinze ans si on se donne ces marqueurs
là qu'on s'en donne les moyens en
faisant attention à ne pas gaspiller
l'argent public
on peut y arriver donc il va falloir
trouver de l'argent on a proposé des
solutions elles ne sont sans doute pas
complète et des spécialistes en
proposerons d'autres
moi j'ai envie de regarder le résultat
je suis soignants je veux que les
enfants français tous mes concitoyens
puisque je suis pédiatre soient
correctement soignés et qu'on me demande
des comptes si je ne les soigne pas bien
avec les moyens que l'ensemble de la
société aura voulu donner choisissez
simplement sur qui m'intéresse c'est un
professionnel de santé
ma dernière question la mobilisation des
hôpitaux le 16 juin à l'appel de douze
syndicats et collectifs et est conservé
déterminez vous voulez être toujours
alors je ne sais pas vous répondre l'âme
je n'ai pas encore discuté avec mes
collègues je pense que pour l'instant je
n'ai pas eu de contre ordre je tiens à
signaler que dans de nombreux hôpitaux
et ça va un nombre croissant toutes les
semaines il y à une mobilisation
hebdomadaire dans l'ensemble des
personnels sur le parvis de leur hôpital
ça s'est passé à saint-etienne ça se
passe à robert debré
ça va se passer à saint-louis ça se
passe à l'hôpital tenon à paris ça s'est
passé dans de nombreuses autres régions
en france à toulouse depuis longtemps
qui portent les revendications que je
viens de vous donner la
donc nous continuons à être mobilisés
avec cette volonté de construire et
surtout pas d'être dans la dénégation
permanente nous avons apporté des choses
nous voulons montrer que nous avons
besoin de réponses fortes à ma
connaissance aujourd'hui cette date du
16 juin n'a pas été remise en cause du
tout merci stéphane augé chef du service
de réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
robert debré d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france la chloroquine les
études se suivent et ne se ressemblent
pas suite à une étude très critique
publié par le land 7 vendredi l' oms
indique ce soir avoir suspendu
temporairement les essais cliniques avec
ce médicament qu'elle mène avec ses
partenaires dans plusieurs pays par
mesure de précaution en france le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
devant lui une révision des règles de
prescription
alors cette molécule est elle oui ou non
dangereuses face au co vite ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
prêt pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec violaine dire un
immunologiste collective
kovy 19 blé sont les médecins à
prescrire bonsoir madame merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france pour
en débattre avec vous laurent alexandre
médecin essayiste bonsoir à vous
également laurent alexandre
alors avant de vous donner la parole je
voudrais qu'on écoute didier raoult le
teint qui s'est donc exprimé comme tous
les lundis sur sa fameuse chaîne youtube
de l'ia chu méditerranée voilà ce qu'il
dit concernant cette étude de l'insee
parue vendredi
si vous ai passé quatre mille malades
dans les mains croyez pas que je vais
changer parce qu'il ya des gens qui font
du big data qui est une espèce de
fantaisie complètement délirante qui
prend des données dont on connaît pas la
qualité qui mélange tout qui mélange des
traitements dont on sait pas quelle est
la dose qu'on a donnés ci se prenait
d'hydroxyde chloroquine on peut se
suicider avec un printemps trop comme
avec le doliprane d'ailleurs qu'est
vraiment en réalité plus d'un joueur qui
doit aussi claudine ce qu'on veut bien
regarder c'est la première cause
d'intoxication dont les pays modernes du
monde le doliprane c'est dangereux et ça
a du bon donc si tu anglais comment
voulez-vous que une étude foireuse fait
avec les big data change ce que nous
envient alors voilà l'étude est foireuse
1 il manque de sérieux selon didier
rahout du coup laurent alexandre est ce
qu'elle permet vraiment de répondre à
notre question ce médicament est il oui
ou non dangereux non l'étude du lancet
été très intéressante et c'est un
message d alerte qui doit nous inquiéter
et nous rendre prudents mais ça n'est
pas une étude prospective randomisée
c'est une étude rétrospective
donc ça nous donne des signaux des
signaux d'alert nous devons faire
particulièrement attention en attendant
que les essai prospectif randomisé
arrive mais nous ne pouvons pas ce soir
affirmé que la potion du professeur à
hoult augmente la mortalité
on ne peut pas l'affirmer à partir des
données que nous avons pour l'affirmer
il faudrait des essais cliniques
randomisés qui vont arriver alors je je
pense
seulement à discovery et puis à recovery
mais également l'étude qui a été lancé
par le n aiacciu aux états unis à
l'instigation de son directeur adjoint
qui est le professeur faut si donc les
données de l'étude du lancet d' sont
inquiétantes il y a pas mal d'études
on pourrait même dire une avalanche de
données inquiétantes récemment les
données du british medical journal ne
sont pas bonnes non plus qui doivent
nous inciter à la prudence
mais il n'est pas possible d'affirmer ce
soir que le protocole du professeur
raoul tu tues davantage que le placebo
on ne peut pas dire ça ce soir mais
certains craignent certains le craignent
suffisamment pour que l'organisation
mondiale de la santé est interrompu son
nez c'est enfin la partie de son essai
qui concerne hydroxyles eurokin pour
vérifier qu'on n'observe pas à avec un
comité spécial qui va regarder quel est
l'état de la mortalité chez les gens qui
sont sous hydroxy chloroquine dans
l'essai qui est organisée sous l'égide
de de l'om est donc ce soir on peut pas
affirmer que ça tue le protocole raul tu
mais certains le craignent notamment
l'om est donc il faut être super frud
dents et je pense qu'il faut maintenant
que les médecins aient conscience du
fait que on a pas mal d'un 10 en
défaveur du protocole raul tu es qu'il
faut faire attention
alors bien sûr à monter de plus plus
excessifs il a dit beaucoup de mal cet
après-midi de tout le monde des revues
scientifiques du big data
on va en parler laurent alex
l'emportement l'emporter ne doit pas
cacher le fait que nous avons en ce
moment une avalanche de signaux négatifs
sur son protocole dont prudence prudence
prudence
oui effectivement verront vous voulez
pas connu pour atteindre un ardent
défenseur du protocole de didier raoul
donc ont apprécié l'honnêteté ce soir ça
ne prouve pas que cette queue et vous
l'avez bien souligné laurent alexandre
law oms indique avoir suspendu
temporairement les essais cliniques avec
ce médicament
violaine guérin ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous regrettez justement
toutes ces études très critiques qui
font que voilà on arrête des essais qui
pourrait peut-être conduire à de bons
résultat qui sait et sauver des mis en
tout cas je vous pose la question que la
guerre merci beaucoup de me donner la
parole donc je précise que je suis
médecin et qui est suivi des patients
atteints par locaux vides
donc j'ai une expérience de terrain et
j'aimerais bien que les personnes qui
prennent la parole et tous suivi des
patients à la fois en phase précoce qui
est la phase du traitement sur laquelle
le professeur raoul tas a insisté qu'il
était important de travailler en phase
précoce pour éviter des complications
pour éviter des passages justement en
hospitalisation et également pour
diminuer la contagiosité puisque l'idée
est de diminuer la charge virale donc ça
c'est un premier point
l'étude dont vous parlez elle est
extrêmement étonnante d'abord parce
qu'elle a été faite sur une base de
données de cardiologues
quand on regarde les groupes et que l'on
compare le groupe contrôle et le groupe
des patients qui ont été traités eh bien
on s'aperçoit déjà que sur plus de 12
paramètres les groupes ne sont pas
comparables à la base et que le groupe
des patients traités est beaucoup plus
grave
alors comme on est sur une base de
données cardiologique c'est pas
tellement étonnant puisque on sait qu'il
faut être prudent lorsqu'on presserait
des drogues si chloroquine et la
chloroquine et là tu es trop micinn à
des patients qui ont des problèmes
cardio à la balle
donc si on regarde bien les populations
à qui cela était proposé en plus dans le
monde entier avec des techniques de
soins qui sont différentes selon les
pays
et bien cette étude finalement elle ne
fait que confirmer une chose c'est que
quand on ne respecte pas bien mais
contre indication de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine et qu'on l'a prescrit à des
gens qui ont des pathologies cardiaques
graves
oui c'est dangereux alors après je suis
extrêmement étonné d attitude à la fois
de l'om s est de même de notre ministre
de la santé qui en plus notre ministre
de la santé a restreint usage de la
coquine avec plusieurs décrets
successifs tracy de manchette
aggrave sous oxygénothérapie donc là il
ya un forte embarras sur le sujet après
ce dont je peux vous témoigner c'est que
le protocole initiée par le professeur
raoul tête et testé en france par des
médecins a été testé dans beaucoup de
pays du monde et avec succès en face
très conne je rappelle parce
qu'effectivement quand on utilise des
drogues si chloroquine chez des patients
qui sont fragiles qui ont peut-être
aussi des atteintes cardiologique du
virus et bien cela n'est pas forcément
une bonne chose
et dans cette étude par exemple on n'a
aucune idée du nombre de patients qui
ont eu des scanners est ce qu on a fait
attention
ainsi ces patients avec des mieux car
dit dépérit qu'un vide demio péricardite
parce qu'aujourd'hui on sait justement
que ce sont ce type d'atteinte avec les
atteintes pulmonaires qui conduit yves à
dd fait ou a des séquelles aussi parce
que c'est cela qu'on est en train
d'observer aujourd'hui donc je comprend
un petit peu même si je ne connais pas
du tout le professeur raoul qui est un
peu en colère contre ses études sous
d'autant plus qu' on a quand même trois
études de son équipe qui ont certes en
particulier pour la première des
critiques mais des méthodologies car
recevoir bien sûr mais je pense qu'il ya
d'autres études également qui ont
conforté dans le monde
les résultats de l'équipe du professeur
raoul qu il ya des pays et on le voit
les pays qui ont prescrit ce qu'ils ont
préconisé son protocole sans forcément
faire les études puisque comme on est un
peu en temps de guerre quelque part des
pays ont donné l'aval pour ce protocole
et on voit très bien que qu'il ya moins
de décès et comme des choses se sont
déplacés et autres on va fondamentale
oui oui nous aurons var on va laisser
aussi parce que c'est un débat
effectivement vous laisser échangés
tous les deux on a évoqué la question du
big data laurent alexandre le professeur
à l'ens qui critique également les big
data en gros il dit voilà moi je fais de
l'humain je compile pas des données vous
êtes un spécialiste d'ailleurs laurent
alexandre de l'intelligence artificielle
vous comprenez quand même le désarroi de
ce professeur qui qui effectivement
c'est une cible pour pour beaucoup et
cet argument qui fait ma voilà moi je ne
compris pas des données je fais de
l'humain l'expérience on va parvenir à
la médecine de 1950 ou à la médecine de
molière on est en 2020 on fait
l'avastine avec des dossiers médicaux
électroniques avec du big data avec de
l'intelligence artificielle
je ne pense pas que les français
souhaitent qu'on revienne au temps des
robes août le autant des médecins de
molière des saignées des clis terre donc
oui la médecine de 2020 un professeur
raoul tu elle se fait avec du big data
elle se fait avec des bases de données
avec de la rigueur scientifique
moissinac aider à rentrer dans la vie or
en tout cas on s'en vend des villas
caron qui ne tue pas finalement
descendre le professeur raoul qui
l'approuvent et qui sauvait 0 vie ces
études sont méthodologie bonnes pour la
poubelle
elles ont des billets qui sont
inacceptables et son grand allié le
professeur peron dont l'étude a été
félicité par monsieur raoul tu es par
madame guérin a été retiré en
catastrophe il y a trois jours si vous
avez tous été deux fois sur cette étude
et puis les dates exactes de vos tweets
madame veut pas dire que cette étude
cette étude a été retiré en catastrophe
pour problèmes méthodologiques
donc voyez le problème c'est qu'on a
dans le clan des rats ou c'est à dire
les études sur défaite à marseille
ellis et les études faites par le
professeur personnes ont des faillites
des faiblesses méthodologiques
absolument épouvantable qui doivent nous
nous nous faire être extrêmement prudent
nous ne pouvons pas prendre de risques
avec les patients pour l'instant on ne
voit pas les effets positifs de ce
protocole
en revanche on en voit les effets
négatifs si vous savez si l'om est
interrompue son essai c'est pas parce
qu'il ya un complot mondial contre le
professeur raoul tu comme certains de
ses fans le pense c'est parce qu'il ya
un vrai doute imaginer qu'on
généraliser qu'on donne à tout le monde
ce protocole alors qu'il augmenterait
significativement la mortalité non
aujourd'hui il faut faire attention
comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure et on
peut pas m'accuser d'être sectaire
l'étude du lancet tu ne permet pas de
trancher définitivement ce sont d essai
randomisé prospectif qui le permettront
mais ces données sont suffisamment
inquiétante pour qu'on fasse attention
il ne faudrait pas qu'on découvre dans
un mois qu'on a tué l'un d'eux malades
avec un médicament qui tuerait davantage
que le placebo qui tuerait davantage que
l'absence de traitement il faut qu'on
soit très vigilant
personnellement je pense que l'om est sa
raison il est important de regarder on
dans les données qui ont déjà été
comptait que collectés dans l'essai
solidarité il est important de vérifier
que ce protocole n'augmente pas la
mortalité des malades parce que notre
but a non médecins ce n'est pas
d'augmenter la mortalité avec des
médicaments
c de la b c donc il faut que nous soyons
certains que ce protocole n'augmente pas
la mortalité et moi très franchement je
vous lance ce soir un l'essai l'étude du
lancet tu ne me permet pas de trancher
ne nous permet pas de nous médecins deux
tranches est gelée dite raisonnée tout
cas la carrière minutieuse mais c'est
quand même oui c'est comme un signal
d'alarmé
ils vont fera-t-on moi je n'exclus plus
ce soir que le protocole raul tu
augmentes la mortalité chez les malades
et vous imaginez la gravité si cette
crainte issues de l'étude du lancet
était confirmée donc soyons très prudent
et le fan club de raul tu dois faire de
meilleures études parce que on a en
parlé il ya deux minutes quand on voit
qu'il a fallu retirer en catastrophe
l'étude du professeur peron qui pourtant
a été à vendre est approuvé et apprécié
par out on se dit qu'il faut faire
attention et qu'il faut faire de la
science de la vraie science de la
science d'aujourd'hui en s'aidant du big
data
contrairement à ce que pense raul parce
qu'on est au siècle de l'informatique
est pas au siècle des médecins de
molière
violaine guérin le mot de la fin on peut
tuer quand même avec ce médicament c'est
un argument qu'il faut entendre tout de
même ça sera le mot de la fin rapidement
oui c'est dommage que je ne puisse pas
parler plus et vous ai laissé la parole
mais pas trop trop long parce qu'on
avait des dérives les sas est long tous
les deux les français apprécient je
pense la médecine de qualité qui est une
médecine on est ausculté les malades et
est pas une médecine ont fait du big
data et je pense que monsieur alexandre
qui a des logiciels à vendre peut-être
parle plutôt de cela on a du mal à
comprendre pourquoi on n'entend pas par
exemple de l'agronome à ce qu on
n'entend pas par exemple c'est quand
même répondre laurent alexandre on va
nous l'espérons mais madame et c'est
malhonnête des diffamatoire quand on a
la parole en dernier
non justement justement laurent
alexandre jamais vu que j'allais vous
donner la parole en voir au var on va
couper la peau tout d'abord le divorce
on va on va vous laisser répondre on va
laisser finir violaine guérin sur son
idée et on vous donnera le mot de la fin
laurent alexandre pour vous puissiez
répondre elle et je pense que le point
fondamental c'est de laisser les
médecins prescrire de décider avec leurs
patients et ce qui est tout à fait à les
financer cette guerre et quand j'entends
monsieur alexandre parler de potions
raul tous deux par les deux camps raul
tout autre les médecins ont simplement
envie d'être tranquille et de prescrire
et pour finir je voudrais dire que il
est inadmissible de ne pas entendre par
exemple que l'équipe du professeur raoul
tu as fait plus de dix mille
électrocardiogramme à des patients qui
ont été suivies qu'il n'y a pas eu de
complication majeure ce que nous
également sur le terrain nous avons
observé qu'en l'hydroxyde chloroquine
est prescrite dans le respect de ses
contre indications et nous avons demandé
à la nfl les données justement de
pharmacovigilance de 2017 2018 2019 qui
montre que globalement il n'y a pas
d'effets indésirables sur cette molécule
qui est connu depuis plus de 40 ans et
qui a été prescrite qu'il n'avait pas
besoin d'être prescrite puisqu'elle
était hors ordonnance jusqu'au 15
janvier 2020 donc ça ça veut aussi dire
quelque chose et
d'autre part on a tous ces patients qui
sont traités par hydroxy chloroquine qui
sont qui ont des maladies qui sont
graves parfois avec des attaques
cardiaques comme des lupus ou d'autres
maladies comme la polyarthrite
rhumatoïde et qu' on n'a jamais eu toute
cette grande guerre pour prescrire ce
médicament
donc je suis extrêmement inquiète de ce
qui se passe parce que en aidant de
l'irrationnel et je penche pour moi en
tant que médecin de base on va dire
laissons nous tranquilles laissons-nous
travailler et on sait faire ça depuis
extrêmement longtemps et cette molécule
que plein de gens aussi en ont eu pour
partir en afrique ou ailleurs
elle n'a jamais vraiment eu et grande
voix là et on va à donner le mot de la
fin très rapidement s'il vous plaît à
laurent alexandre parce qu'on est arrivé
là je vais je vais juste dire que le
procédé dégueulasse qui est de dire que
les gens sont vendus quand ils ne sont
pas favorables à l'idrac cycloclean
c'est vraiment très moche je jure sur
l'honneur de n'avoir aucun conflit
d'intérêts dans cette affaire
je n'ai pas de logiciels à vendre
contrairement à ce que dit madame guérin
de façon parfaitement dégueulasse et je
n'ai d'intérêt ni en faveur de la
chloroquine ni en saveurs des
concurrents de la chloroquine et tout le
discours du clan raul qui est de dire
que les gens qui sont dans notre coin de
la route
so vendu à gilles ead est dégueulasse en
tout cas moi je jure sur l'honneur que
je n'ai aucun conflit d'intérêts madame
ce que vous avez dit et diffamatoires et
c'est vraiment dégueulasse
merci en tout cas de droit de réponse
laurent alexandre et violaine guerre
merci d'avoir accepté le débat il est
20h30 en direct sur rt france on évoque
le bilan désormais de l'épidémie
coronavirus dans l'hexagone chiffres de
la mortalité ne sera communiqué que
demain selon la direction générale de la
santé le nombre de patients en
réanimation continue
décroître on compte 1609 malades en
soins intensifs contre 1998 il ya une
semaine ses 46 de moins qu'hier le
chiffre baisse sans discontinuer depuis
avril quant au nombre de personnes
sortis guéris de l'hôpital depuis le
début de l'épidémie il s'établit à 65
milles 180 19
cette question à présent est si un
outsider était candidat à la
présidentielle de 2000 22 c'est en tout
cas ce qu emmanuel macron craindre et
selon nos confrères du monde et cela
alors que l'exécutif est face à une
défiance grandissante des français est
accentuée par la crise du coc vide 19 et
celle farges l'humoriste jean marie
bigard le polémiste eric zemmour le
professeur didier raoult ou encore
philippe de villiers emmanuel macron a
multiplié les contacts ces dernières
semaines avec des personnalités en
dehors de la sphère politique
selon nos confrères du journal le monde
le chef de l'état redouterait
l'émergence d'un candidat antisystème à
la présidentielle de 2000 22,1 zemmour
un raul tu 1 à nouna pourquoi pas une
elise lucet qui incarnent chacun à leur
manière cette rupture entre le peuple et
les élites peuvent faire irruption dans
le jeu et tenter de poursuivre la vague
de dégagements de 2017
le chef de l'état a donc redoublé
d'attention pour ses figures considéré
comme populaire exemple avec jean marie
bigard pendant le confinement dans une
vidéo publiée sur les réseaux sociaux
l'humoriste s'est attaqué au
gouvernement la plan notamment à rouvrir
les bars ont ré ouvre donc à partir de
lundi les métros les trains les avions
qui auront bientôt 70 % de remplissage
nous dit on
bourgault rouvre pas les bars au mans
serait pas mal aubin on sait aussi se
tenir comme dans le métro où comme dans
le train comme on va être obligé de le
faire c'est à dire à un met on peut
quand même discuter le bout de gras
ce coup de gueule s'est soldée par un
coup de fil chez nos confrères de sud
radio jean marie bigard a indiqué qu
emmanuel macron l'avait appelé en
personne
l'humoriste a ainsi assuré que le chef
de l'état lui avait donné
une information que l'elysée n'a pas
confirmé les jean marie bigard n'est pas
le seul à avoir reçu un coup de
téléphone du chef de l'état on peut
citer aussi eric zemmour le président de
la république a décroché son téléphone
le 1er mai dernier pour prendre des
nouvelles du polémiste après son
agression dans la rue de la capitale
conversations téléphoniques mais aussi
déplacement le 9 avril dernier emmanuel
macron s'est rendu à marseille pour
rencontrer le professeur didier raoult
une personnalité qualifiée d'anti
système et que la crise du coronavirus a
fait émerger notamment à travers le
débat controversé sur la chloroquine
dans les colonnes de paris match didier
raoult avait ainsi fait l'éloge du chef
de l'état le qualifiant d' homme
intelligent qui comprend tous les porte
parole de la contestation dont le chef
de l'état tente de capter la popularité
pour reprendre les propos rapportés par
le quotidien le monde de l'analyste
politique jérôme sainte marie
une façon aussi de se rapprocher de la
france populaire alors qu emmanuel
macron est perçu comme un symbole de
l'élitisme mondialistes cela lui permet
de toucher des publics qu'ils ne
touchent pas habituellement et de
réactiver l'image d'un homme qui ne
serait pas du sérail comme il se l'était
construite lors de la campagne de 2010
est une stratégie qui pourrait permettre
à emmanuel macron de désamorcer
l'éventuelle émergence d'une
personnalité hors système de la
présidentielle de 2000 22
un scénario qui n'est pas sans rappeler
la saison 3 des thrillers politiques
baron noir produit par canal + dans
laquelle un blogueur antisystème et
populaire chamboule tout une campagne
présidentielle et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct avec denis demonpion
éditeurs réalisent bonsoir denis
demonpion merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors selon vous ces craintes rapportées
par nos confrères du monde ce qu'elles
sont crédibles elles sont un petit peu
grotesque en réalité parce que pour deux
raisons c'est que déjà on est à un an et
demi au moins de la présidentielle donc
il est encore bien trop tôt pour comment
dirais-je spéculer sur qui sera pas
candidat bon pour le moment il ya une
candidate déclarée c'est marine le pen
qui je crois il ya déjà deux trois mois
a clairement dit qu'elle serait candidat
qu'elle porterait les couleurs du
rassemblement national ce qui n'était
pas vraiment une surprise en soi et
maintenant que le chef de l'état sa muse
et surtout que les journaux rapportent
de manière aussi officiel ces
conversations privées avec jean-marie
bigeard eric zemmour etc etc
proxi de raout bon sa rencontre
d'ailleurs sa visite chez procédera août
avait été un petit peu mise en scène il
ya plus grave il ya plus urgent j'allais
dire après deux mois de comics 19
l'économie est très mal en point dans ce
pays
d'ailleurs il n'est pas encore reparti
l'endettement de la france à être
colossal les déficits également le
chômage n'en parlons pas et je pense que
le président la république serait plus
comment dirais-je une idée là même de
traiter ces questions plutôt que de
passer son temps au téléphone
justement quel est l'intérêt pour le
président de la république de
communiquer sur ses appels à ses
personnages parfois controversés enfin
en l'occurrence et jean marie bigard qui
a communiqué lui sur le fait que le
président l'avait appelé mais il
n'empêche ça se sait il ya bien un
intérêt qu à emmanuel macron à plat non
écoutez c'est un peu les qu'une de la
politique si je se dire car
bon vous l'avez 10 gens râlent bigeard a
annoncé sur une radio que vont le
président de la république l'avait
appelé mais si c'est pour comment
dirais-je prévenir d'éventuelles
candidatures parce que c'est vrai que le
nom d'eric zemmour était revenue de
manière un peu plus sérieuse après sa
prestation devant un aréopage de membres
du rassemblement national et des droites
assez dur là il était apparu comme
quelqu'un susceptible d'être un candidat
sérieux
on n'en est pas là parce que c'est pas
la première fois dans les élections
présidentielles et même des mois avant
que il ya comme ça des chevau légers
dont on donne des noms il ya eu dans le
passé vous avez deux exemples marquants
ça a été le premier le comédien yves
montand c'est vrai à l'époque qui était
un comédien extrêmement populaire et
d'ailleurs des gens de gauche avaient
essayé de trouver une troisième voie à
gauche en promouvant sa candidature
malheureusement il y avait eu des
émissions de télé c'est autour de lui et
puis ça n'a jamais abouti et le candidat
le plus sérieux en réalité ça a été co
luce vous avez dans les années 80 moritz
lui était quand même crédité dans les
sondages alors il avait une vraie
popularité
contrairement à didier out c'est quand
même un épiphénomène j'allais dire eric
zemmour même chose
jean marie bigard remet non parlons pas
on voit mal ces trois hommes prétendre
sérieusement à la présidentielle
maintenant c'est leur droit
c'est pas la première fois qu'ils
auraient des candidats un peu j'allais
dire fantaisistes et y en a eu
d'ailleurs à la présidentielle de 1965
des candidats qui font 1% il ya toujours
d'ailleurs observé françois asselineau
qui a quelques ennuis d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui avec certains des membres de
son parti qui régulièrement se remet en
selle pour essayer de faire passer ses
idées
mention pardon de vous couper mais enfin
vous sous-estimez un petit peu cette se
pendent de l'opinion publique qui
effectivement est peut-être vous voulez
on appelle ça comme ça on ti système ça
a été le cas notamment aussi en italie
ou beppe grillo se souvient un humoriste
a fini par être élu vous n'y croyez pas
du tout c'est quelque chose dont les
financements avec un mouvement d'un
gilet jaune très fort en france
notamment
mais regardez mouvement jean joulin avis
que ça allait donner quand ils se sont
présentés aux élections municipales et
européennes qui n'ont pratiquement pas
fait voir non l'assaut des personnalités
individuelles
ça n'a rien à voir avec le la manière
dont emmanuel macron lui-même qu'il
n'était pas d'ailleurs hors système
puisque il avait fait quand même ces
armes à la fois sous nicolas sarkozy et
françois hollande est bien il avait
constitué un parti il une organisation
autour de lui qui est absolument
indispensable pour pouvoir percer dans
une élection comme ça que je sache
aujourd'hui didier rahout qui est sans
doute un professeur émérite remarquer
etc
il n'a pas cette infrastructure derrière
lui pas plus d'ailleurs qu'eric zemmour
et encore moins genre à ibiza jean marie
bigard pousse un coup de gueule pour
qu'en effet on ouvre les bistrots c'est
peut-être très populaire mais je ne sais
pas combien de temps cette popularité
les commentaires âge s'imprégnera dans
le paysage politique et tout sera
véritablement l'opinion publique je
pense que l'opinion attend des gens qui
répondent à leurs problèmes apporte des
solutions aux questions qu'ils se posent
et je dirais un peu de sérieux et donner
de mon option d'avoir été avec nous et
on en revient donc à la crise du
coronavirus du côté économique à partir
du 1er juin l'état n'assurera plus la
prise en charge complète du chômage
partiel mis en place au début du
confinement
la déclaration du ministre de l'économie
tout en précisant qu'elle sera je cite
raisonnable
les salariés ne perdront rien ce sont
les employeurs qui vont devoir payer un
peu plus a précisé le patron de bercy
les entreprises assureront 15% du coup
dès le 1er juin selon le ministère du
travail
en revanche pour les secteurs qui ne
reprendront pas leur activité au 1er
juin là c'est gras l'it et du chômage
partiel sera maintenu a également
précisé bruno le maire et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec henri
sterdyniak économiste à l'observatoire
français des conjonctures économiques
membres du collectif des économistes
atterrés
bonsoir henri sterdyniak merci d'être
avec nous alors on l'a appris 1
en fin d'après-midi les entreprises
assureront 15% du coup dès le 1er juin
plus en tout cas de prise en charge
complète à partir de cette date
votre réaction d'abord j'avais mis en
place un système qui était extrêmement
généreux puisque l'état prenait en
charge en totalité le salaire de
personnes qui restaient chez eux
ce système a très bien fonctionné
puisque la france n'a pas connu de
fortes eu jusqu'à présent de forte
poussée du chômage
comme on a pu le voir ou aux états unis
c'est un système qui naturellement doit
petit à petit être mis en extension
parce que il faut que les gens
retournent au travail
la grande question c'est de savoir est
ce que on ne met pas en extinction trop
tôt sachant qu' il reste encore beaucoup
d'entre eux près de 2,2 cas où les
salariés ne peuvent pas venir travailler
pour des raisons de transport pour des
raisons d'enfants et du port ils ont de
garde temps forts et là c'est peut-être
un peu tôt vous pensez qu'on avait les
moyens en france vu l'ampleur de la
dette publique de prolonger cette mesure
qui coûte effectivement très très cher à
l'état
cette mesure coûte à peu près 24
milliards par mois
disons c'est partager 16 milliards à
l'état 1 8 milliard à l'unedic ce qui ce
qui va poser problème
dans les années à venir parce que
l'unedic va avoir une dette très
importante
bon c'est une généralité dans leur
ensemble des pays on accepte le
gonflement de la de la dette publique
c'est une nécessité de la situation
actuelle un peu partout les dettes
publiques vont augmenter donc s'il
conséquences de la crise autre question
henri sterdyniak on attend des annonces
un douar philippe l'a dit aujourd'hui
pour jeudi concernant les cafés
restaurants les hôtels c'est un pas très
important évidemment l'économie de notre
pays qu'est ce qui est souhaitable selon
vous en termes de réouverture notamment
nous avons comme toujours un arbitrage à
faire entre d'un côté le souci de la
santé ce qui la santé des individus et
de l'autre le souci de l'économie ont il
faut voir que les français ont été très
frappé psychologiquement par la crise
que beaucoup ont envie de souffler mot
court envie de prendre des vacances ils
tant qu' il est assez légitime qu'on
prenne un petit risque est que
relativement rapidement on dise aux
jambes 1 vous pourrez partir en vacances
à partir du 1er janvier
à partir du 1er juillet et donc on
comprend là la position du la position
du gouvernement
il faut que les gens maintiennent et les
gestes barrière mais pour sauver un
certain nombre de secteurs économiques
pour redonner un peu de goût d'ogives
aux français il faut obligatoirement
relâcher les mesures relativement
rapidement entre disons qu'au cours du
mois de juin
il ya beaucoup effectivement pack étude
sur cette crise certains prédisent voilà
de vraies catastrophes vous en tant
qu'économiste quelles sont vos
prévisions
si j'ose dire vous pensez que les
français vont recommencer à consommer de
manière importante et remonter un petit
peu relancer l'économie jusqu'à présent
d'après ce qu'on a pu voir à particulier
en chine la remontée est très lente les
les individus hopper pendant très
longtemps de retourner dans les magasins
ils ont peur des que ils ont peur d'être
comptable et surtout ils ont pas l'
enthousiasme pour se lancer dans tes
achats en particulier dans des achats de
l'us les gens vont devoir retourner dans
les restaurants
si on leur dit que en fait ils sont dans
des bulles en plastique tout ça fait que
naturellement la reprise va prendre un
certain temps et d'autres qu'il faut
avoir un discours un peu optimiste et
dire aux deux jambes
voilà pour sauver l'économie bat il faut
absolument que vous acceptiez de refaire
des des achats objectivement le
sentiment naturel des gens ces deux en
quelque sorte de ce2 de rester chez eux
d'éviter les achats de faire des
économies et ça nous entraîne dans une
spirale très dangereuse et donc il faut
prendre sur soi il faut absolument
repartir refaire des achats ce nom
l'économie ne repartira pas et c'est là
la difficulté la situation et je suis
bien que on a été atteint
psychologiquement il faut absolument
retrouver les chemins de du des magasins
sachant qu elle tangue dans deux trois
mois va bien sûr faudra poser la
question comment on prend le tournoi
écologique
merci en guise de naître des achats
pendant quelques mois pour relancer la
machine
merci henri sterdyniak d'avoir été avec
mon en direct sur rtl france
l'état belge a visé par des plaintes
pour sa gestion de crise sanitaire à une
quarantaine de personnes estiment que
les mesures de confinement imposé était
trop restrictive arguments avancés des
contraintes qui irait à l'encontre de
plusieurs articles de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme
principal ministères visés celui de
l'intérieur dont le locataire qui est
terre de crem d'éclat attendre une
citation à comparaître écouter l'un des
avocats des plaignants fo qui a conquis
le forez mais cela l'apport d'une hes
sont très faibles
il démonte un problème mais quand on va
dans le détail on va voir que tous les
chiffres ils sont où les élites et les
étals où elle mais ce sont en effet pas
certain pas sûr et à la fin il faut du
recul on ne sait presque rien de secret
russe et on a pris des mesures qui peut
douter l'efficacité mais aussi en plus d
un
si ces mesures sont bien conformes aux
droits de l'homme techniques qui sont
prévus dans dans le traité il est vrai
que la section de droit possibles
il ya là des conditions d'abord il vaut
d'avoir une finalité précise et
objectivement qu'on pouvait t on à des
dessous
en ce qui concerne seulement les iem ans
il faut prendre les mesures qui
correspond bien à ce à ses pulsions et
troisièmement ils doivent y être une
proportionnalité entre les mesures
prises et l'objectif des mesures et au
mans ce que c'est que ces conditions ne
sont pas remplies
on va revoir tous les mesures qui sont
prises
il est clair que nous sommes pas contre
des mesures en général mais il faudra
les prévus mais des mesures qui sont
très précis
on sait très bien il se trouve dans les
lits de soins intensifs et on doit
prendre des mesures pour protéger ces
gens
on va pas prendre des mesures qui
limitent les droits des autres gens il
faut il faut se diriger à la personne
qui sont en danger et pas aux autres
personnes il avait déjà des procédures
en allemagne plusieurs villes ont déjà
annulé sous des mesures ont été prises
mais aussi en hollande un codec sont
entrés maintenant de commencer une
procédure contre l'état et dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous parlerons
du ségur de la santé lancée aujourd'hui
par edouard philippe en crise et en
première ligne face aux coronavirus le
secteur hospitalier attend des mesures
concrètes dont une hausse des salaires
et puis nous reviendrons sur les propos
polémiques de la chanteuse camélia
jordana sur la police et savent qu'à ses
nerfs ne saisira pas la justice mais le
syndicat alliance police nationale lui a
écrit au procureur de paris
[Musique]
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doit selon vont jouer
à levin et quel rôle joue-t-elle dans
les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils n'étaient pas préparés
c'est là mais les villes elles se sont
connectés tout de suite entre elles pour
voir comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques de matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront rassembler les îles
comment est-ce qu'elles vont se
transformer après la pandémie la crise
maintenant à fait bien comprendre qu'on
peut pas s'oublier des banlieues on peut
pas oublier les quartiers pauvres parce
que véritablement être en partie de la
vie donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte n est pas pas seulement d'elle
même elle parle aussi de comment
caissettes cercle vertueux avec les
villes des alentours
et
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même on
vit tous les jours sans faire attention
que tout en dépend c'est l'unité de
mesure de toute chose une convention
admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
est ce qu'on sait combien d'enfants sont
victimes de ces violences et qui sont
concernés par ces drames qui se déroule
dans le huis clos familial pendant la
période actuelle il est difficile de
dire précisément combien d'enfants sont
concernés car en fait on a très peu de
visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le lise
ils redisent là le problème c'est que
dans le cas du confinement il n'y a plus
cet entourage et tout se fait à distance
ce qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude un porte
plutôt sur ce que vous pouvez m'en pas
la partie immergée de l'iceberg en fait
parce que les très difficile pour les
enfants malgré tout d'après eux mêmes et
dans ce cas là on n'entend rien ça se
fait totalement dans le silence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques et sur ces sujets sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon autorisation
dans la crise ducobu 19
c'est toute une chaîne décisionnelle
médicales administratives et politiques
irresponsables puis fiesque alors que
l'on aime s recommandait le port du
masque par les populations la parole
publique a longtemps menti sur sa
nécessité pour ne pas avouer la triste
absence du stop regret la décision de
confinement s'imposait compte-tenu du
manque de matériel permettant d'autres
solutions mais en freinant l'hécatombe
on pénalise l'économie l'état ne pourra
plus être l'état providence que nous
avons que tu pourras n'aura été
cimetière de certaines espérances en
pensant que le progrès faisait de nous
des hommes dieu et que les technocrates
avec les du monde demain des
conséquences de la crise oblige à
repenser nos modèles la découverte du
télétravail l'intérêt de consommer des
produits locaux le besoin de solidarité
vont faire évoluer une population qui a
découvert qu'elle était mortel
[Musique]
et
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et d'un fonds talents de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant et on
refermait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais quel une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend quelle
valeur on attribuait la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
morales un débat éthique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas des signes ici d'aujourd'hui en
france l'écho et les violences existait
avant leur confinement
et pendant ce compliment c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre lecture les taux
de féminicide a plus que je dis pas
doublé mais bien monté forcément on n'a
pas encore tous les chiffres officiels
c'est très difficile gros n'est jamais
n'est jamais loin finalement c'est le
confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya un huis clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences
de nombreux endroits à croix
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit c'est
qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs
parce qu'ici seul interdit d'interdire
[Musique]
le virus agit plus sur les poumons sur
le cerveau si j'ai bien compris et donc
ça me paraît difficile d'imaginer un
monde totalement différent la pandémie
va pas avoir changé fondamentalement les
règles du jeu et les règles de la vie
quotidienne selon patrick artus la crise
du collègue 19 pourrait sonner le glas
du capitalisme néolibéral c'est un choc
exogène c'est quelque chose qui est
arrivé de l'extérieur il traduit pas une
défaillance du système économique
capitaliste mondialisé marocaine vivant
le virus a servi de catalyseur
mais les problèmes étaient déjà là les
problèmes de gilet jaune s'adapte pas de
du virus
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième démission il est 21h
heure française tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce lundi 25 mai
hausse significative des salaires et
changements dans le quotidien à
l'hôpital dans les tout prochains mois
la déclaration d loire philippe qui
vient d'ouvrir le ségur de la santé une
visioconférence avec 300 acteurs du
milieu hospitalier pour répondre aux
préoccupations des soignants éprouvé par
la crise du coronavirus christophe
castaner ne va pas saisir la justice
après les propos polémiques de la
chanteuse camélia jordana sur la police
et libertés du débat public ne permet
pas de lire tout et n'importe quoi
affirmé le ministre l'intérieur
le syndicat alliance police nationale a
lui écrit au procureur de paris alors
que paris doit annoncer jeudi
les arbitrages de la phase 2 du
déconfinement les autres capitales
européennes poursuivent leur levée
progressive des restrictions en italie
les salles de sport reprenne les
terrasses rouvre en espagne le royaume
uni lui prévoit de rouvrir les commerces
en juin et si l'europe se déconfit de
l'amérique latine elle subit de plein
fouet la pandémie le continent et le
nouvel épicentre du comique 19 selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
principaux pays infectés dans la région
le braz le brésil un cycle pérou le
système éducatif pâti de la crise
sanitaire
[Musique]
le ségur de la santé s'est donc ouvert
aujourd'hui entre problèmes structurels
au sein des hôpitaux et
dysfonctionnements durant la pandémie de
kobe 19 les attentes des soignants sont
évidemment nombreuses les précisions de
cyrielle bruit cette semaine pour
refonder le système hospitalier en
france c'est l'objectif que s'est fixé
le ségur de la santé lancé ce lundi
quelques 300 représentants du secteur se
sont réunis par visioconférence au tour
du ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
et du premier ministre edouard philippe
rémunération temps de travail
coordination entre la médecine de ville
et l'hôpital
autant de questions auxquelles devront
répondre les deux ministres la
revalorisation des soignants sera
significative la façon dont l'économie
de l'hôpital fonctionne a démontré
toutes ses limites il faut trouver
d'autres méthodes
la t2a ne doit plus être la seule
boussole de l'hôpital français c'est
avec une promesse de changement dans le
quotidien du personnel hospitalier que
le premier ministre a choisi d'ouvrir ce
secure de la santé un personnel
hospitalier fortement mobilisés et
présents aux alentours du ministère
concerné ces soignants attendent des
actes concrets face aux revendications
qu'il porte depuis des années pour
certains et étant donné que ça fait
quand même pas mal de temps déjà qu'on
demande et que
ne serait-ce que là avec le
sous-effectif on est tous plus tôt on
attend de voir
on attend de voir on continue d'appeler
à la mobilisation parce qu'on a bien
conscience que on n'aura que ce qu'on
ira chercher et que le rapport de force
est notre outil pour rentrer dans la
négociation et ce rapport de force on
leur cherche à travers les mardis de la
colère les jeudis de la colère et puis
plus largement sur l'ensemble du
territoire dans une mobilisation des
hospitaliers
plus de 100000 dit qu'on était fermé
depuis 15 ans et ça c'est pas normal et
donc on l'a vu là justement sur la
gestion de la crise où il nous a manqué
des lits il a fallu rouvrir des services
qui étaient fermés mais quand il est
avec une grosse grosse vétusté est donc
là il a fallu rouvrir ça et faire dans
l'urgence on l'a fait y'a pas de soucis
c'est notre job c'est ce que je dis on
en compte dix vous êtes des héros vous
êtes non on n'est pas des héros enfin
moi je me considère pas comme un héros
jeu on est payé pour faire un job on a
fait notre job m'a lancé des conditions
qu'on l'a fait qu'ils sont complètement
déplorable et c'est pour ça aussi on est
là il faut pas qu'ils nous aurons le
gouvernement promet une nouvelle
organisation du système de santé sur
l'ensemble du territoire
reste à savoir s'il sera en mesure de
répondre aux revendications cibler des
soignants en première ligne depuis le
début de la pandémie de kovy de 19 et
pour en parler nous sommes avec thierry
amouroux porte parole du syndicat
national des professionnels infirmiers
bonsoir thierry amouroux merci d'être
avec nous edouard philippe qui promet
donc que le quotidien des personnels
soignant à l'hôpital changerait dans les
tout prochains mois votre quotidien donc
ça laisse présager des changements
concrets la crise du coc vide aura au
moins servi à cela selon vous vous êtes
relativement confiant on n y sommes
confiant dans le soutien de la
population qui s'est manifestée tous les
soirs à 20h et donc qui a obligé le
gouvernement à évoluer un peu sur ses
positions
mais malheureusement pour l'instant on
en reste aux grands principes c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui c'était une grand
messe visioconférence avec 300 personnes
et
ben on a eu droit à un exercice de style
un cours magistral
simplement on aurait préféré plutôt que
d'avoir un prof de français qui fait une
policière tation un prof de maths qui
avance des chiffres précis de combien
nous allons être revalorisées combien de
lits vont être ouverts et combien de
personnes vont être recrutées dans les
hôpitaux
c'est les trois choses que l'on
attendait et on n'a pas de réponse
chiffrée donc alors le seigneur ne fait
qu'ouvrir il a ouvert aujourd'hui parmi
les axes il ya celui de l'investissement
massif ça veut dire quelque chose pour
vous vous avez bon espoir que le nom de
lee augmente notamment avec cette crise
inquiète mis en valeur en exergue le
manque de lits évidemment de nos
hôpitaux publics
effectivement tous les français ont pu
constater que la france n'avait que ça
me lit de réanimation alors que
l'allemagne en avait cinq fois plus et
du coup ils ont eu quatre fois moins de
deux morts donc nous on attend qu'on
rouvre délit on n'a pas arrêté d'en
fermer depuis vingt ans des petits
hôpitaux des des maternités des urgences
ont été fermées les uns après les autres
voilà il est temps de rouvrir un nombre
de lits conséquent pour répondre aux
besoins de santé de la population qui
entre-temps a augmenté en taille on est
8 millions de plus qu'il ya 20 ans nous
avons également une population
vieillissante ya de plus en plus de 2 81
ans à d une population qui a également
développé plus de maladies chroniques
donc il est important d'avoir une
réponse au nombre de lits et au nom de
soignants parce que en allemagne il ya
trente fois plus d'infirmières qu'en
france alors il ya aussi évidemment on
le sait la question des salaires qui
vous préoccupe particulièrement pour
arriver à peu près à la moyenne
européenne il vous en faudrait en tout
cas c'est ce que
les soignants sont ferrailleur de ma
part peut-être pas votre syndicat mais
en tout cas la majorité 300 euros par
mois est ce que ça vous semble réaliste
aujourd'hui vous y croyez à cette
augmentation conséquente
oui le le chiffre de 300 euros et est
partagé par tous y compris par le
gouvernement parce que c'est des études
internationales qui ont montré le
différentiel entre le salaire infirmier
français et le salaire infirmiers moyen
dans l'ensemble de l'union européenne et
donc nous sommes sous payés de 3 euros
par rapport à nos collègues des autres
pays ce qui pose un problème de
recrutement d'attractivité et du coup il
ya des postes qui restent vacants parce
que bâle être sous payés en
sous-effectif il faut pour travailler
dans des conditions déplorables
je rappelle que pendant le coc vide on a
été un certain nombre à porter des sacs
poubelles sur le dos faute d'avoir
d'aidé sur blues manquent de deux
masques également donc effectivement ça
fait quand même réfléchir
donc on attend une revalorisation
salariale le importante
on espère qu'il va pas être étalés non
plus sur sur 20 ans parce que si on nous
sort vous allez être valorisée 2 300
euros mais vous aurez 15 euros de plus
chaque année jusqu'à atteindre cette
somme on en prend pour 20 ans donc ça ne
correspond pas aux attentes non plus
dernière question c'est nicole notât
qu'on connaît bien vu en demies de
syndicalistes qui est chargé en vain de
sa conviction de négocier c'est que
toben fort au pont vont pas du tout non
c'est une personne très controversé
indépendamment de ces positions très
très hostile aux salariés lorsqu'elles
étaient responsables de la cfdt
elle a également présidé une
organisation qui s'appelle le siècle qui
rassemble des des hauts fonctionnaires
des responsables de deux médias re des
responsables politiques ultra libéraux
donc non c'est un très mauvais signal
c'est même une provocation pour
les salariés donc la mobilisation va
continuer plus que jamais avec un
notamment la journée du 16 juin
oui nous sommes une douzaine
d'organisations a appelé à une journée
de mobilisation populaire donc c'est pas
une grande manifestation nationale
ce qu'on cherche à avoir des des
mobilisations locales autour des 1000
hôpitaux français et des 7200 ehpad pour
que chacun dans sa ville d'enfance puis
se manifester son soutien aux soignants
donc le s'est joint à l'heure qui
conviendra et dans le respect des des
gestes barrières mais une multitude
d'actions locales pour montrer que sur
l'ensemble du territoire la population
soutient toujours les soignants et nous
invitons également la population à faire
pression sur le maire qui président de
l'instance qui gère l'hôpital et auprès
des parlementaires qui chaque année vote
le budget des hôpitaux et qui diminue
nos moyens chaque année donc il faut
vraiment faire pression auprès de vos
élus locaux merci à vous thierry
amouroux d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france est parallèlement à ce
ségur de la santé manifestation cet
après-midi de soignants devant l'hôpital
henri mondor à créteil dans le
val-de-marne ont fait le point sur place
avec notre reporter monnaie à modelo le
personnel soignant s'est mobilisée juste
devant l'hôpital henri mondor à créteil
pour porter haut et fort leurs
revendications à savoir une
revalorisation des salaires et les
meilleures conditions de travail il faut
le dire elle ses revendications et sont
au coeur de la mobilisation des hôpitaux
depuis des années déjà on se souvient
juste avant le confinement de ces
grandes manifestations de la part des
urgentistes des médecins et des
infirmiers
cette journée n'a pas été choisie au
hasard puisque c'est aujourd'hui
qu'olivier vers ans avait entamé les
négociations avec les professionnels de
santé pour améliorer les conditions de
travail
on a pu parler à quelques soignants ou
encore médecins et demandé leur avis je
vous propose de les écouter on a porté
haut et fort d'euros
indication d'accord les personnels ici
présents arrive à se libérer pour
descendre et pourquoi je dis il arrive à
se libérer parce qu on est tellement
influent tendue que eux mêmes pour
descendre dans la rue et pouvoir
exprimer leurs revendications et leurs
et leur colère on n'y arrive pas on
arrivait au bout de notre système
concrètement on est à saturation dans
les hôpitaux dans aux urgences on le
voit très bien nos collègues ont
manifesté on fait grève
l'année dernière et en fait les urgences
et la première rentrée c'est la porte
d'entrée de l'hôpital comme on dit mais
sauf que le problème que qu'à nos
collègues des urgences il est le reflet
en fait du problème hospitalier en
général j'ai attendu le concret qu'on
nous le donne le concret des paroles des
paroles c'est bien beau depuis de temps
nos salaires ont été gelés depuis je ne
sais combien d'années ça n'avance pas
ça n'avance pas donc non on attend du
concret vous l'avez entendu le personnel
soignant attend beaucoup de ces
nouvelles négociations avec le
gouvernement emmanuel macron lui avait
reconnu le 15 mai une erreur de
stratégie dans les réformes engagées en
2017 dans le domaine de la santé
ces réformes elles sont donc très
attendues et à la mi-juillet des
nouvelles annonces sont prévues les
violences policières à nouveau au coeur
d'une polémique cette fois ci c'est la
chanteuse camélia jordana également
actrice française qui a choisi
d'interpeller le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner à ce sujet les
explications en images tout d'abord
[Musique]
il y a des milliers de personnes qui ne
se sentent pas en sécurité face à un
flic et j'en fais partie
aujourd'hui j'ai les cheveux défrisés
quand j'ai les cheveux frisés je ne me
sens pas en sécurité face à un flic en
france non madame les hommes et les
femmes qui vont travailler tous les
matins en banlieue ne se font pas
massacrer pour le nul autre raison que
leur couleur de peau ses propos
mensongers et honteux alimente la haine
et la violence il appelle une
condamnation sans réserve
[Musique]
épatés par toutes ces réactions
enthousiastes par la réouverture du
débat public
je ne m'exprimerai pas dans les médias
suite aux nombreuses sollicitations en
réaction aux propos de christophe
castaner je serai en revanche honoré de
débattre en direct avec lui sur le
plateau de son choix
[Musique]
très attaché à la liberté du débat
public surtout dans des émissions qui
sont dédiés à cela et donc je n'entend
pas poursuivre les propos par contre la
liberté du débat public ne permet pas de
dire tout et n'importe quoi
et donc j'ai souhaité dénoncer ces
propos là ensuite il ya la liberté du
débat il y à des procédures encore les
syndicats ont engagé des procédures sur
ce sujet là
[Musique]
non
et les propos de camélia jordana font
polémique depuis 48 heures hashtag a
même vu le jour sur les réseaux sociaux
hashtag je ne me sens pas en sécurité
face à un flic d'où notre question ce
soir les français ont-ils peur de la
police c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre nous
sommes toujours en direct par skype
skype avec david guiraud porte-parole
jeunesse la france insoumise bonsoir
david guiraud merci d'être avec nous à
ses côtés pour en débattre
olivier reverdy secrétaire national
adjoint alliance police bonsoir à vous
merci également à d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors david olivier
reverdy notre syndicat a appelé
christophe castaner à saisir la justice
après les propos de camélia jordana
finalement il annoncé ce soir qu'il
n'allait pas le faire à ce que vous
regrettez
cette décision non alors pour être plus
précis on a appelé deux choses on a
appelé christophe castaner à saisir de
la faire mais d'un autre côté nous avons
aussi saisi le procureur de la
république de paris afin qu'ils exercent
l'opportunité des poursuites qui est de
sa responsabilité
donc aujourd'hui on prend acte des
propos de notre ministre de l'intérieur
de ne pas déposer plainte
on peut le regretter mais en attendant
alliance a quand même saisi le pro 2 le
parquet de paris afin qu'ils se
saisissent lui-même de cette affaire
sans sans la volonté de notre ministre
avant de donner la parole évidemment à
david guiraud c'était important pour
vous justement de saisir le procureur de
la république pour quelles raisons bien
évidemment c'est important parce que ces
propos sont inacceptables et on aurait
aimé que madame jordana fasse parler
d'elle par son talent plutôt par ses
propos haineux encore une fois
stigmatisé la police comme elle le fait
dans le climat qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui quand elle parle de massacre
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement fort
et essayer de certainement pas la
réalité la réalité de ce qui se passe en
france est aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
les tensions qu'il peut y avoir dans
notre société
dans les policiers mais aussi
les pompiers mais aussi tout ce qui
représente l'ordre dans ce pays est
toujours sujet à débat et à attention il
ya violence ultra violence on le voyait
des guets-apens régulièrement il ya des
rodéos sauvages
il ya des policiers qui lorsqu'ils
quittent leurs services se font suivre
par des individus jusque vers leur
domicile de manière à exercer des
violences et des intimidations
vous avez on l'a vu tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis de nombreuses années donc
il s'agit pas aujourd'hui de jeter
l'opprobre sur l'ensemble des policiers
mais c'est pour ça que ces propos sont
inacceptables et on les condamne et on
demande à ce que le procureur de la
république de paris en face d'eux mêmes
david guiraud donc à sanair christophe
castaner qui ne saisit pas la justice
mais le procureur de la république lui
est saisie vous comprenez quand même la
colère de david olivier reverdy et son
besoin justement de saisir les autorités
non je pourrais la limite entendre ce
que pourrait dire un policier l'andam et
en s'agissant d'alliance police pardon
mais vous avez des indignations vient
sélectif
regardez par exemple si vous ne vouliez
pas que le débat public que soit attisé
regarder ça c'est un journaliste vous
voyez vous avez fait une affiche sur un
journaliste vous comparez un chien voilà
ça c'est alliance police a donc je sais
pas comment vous envisagez vous le débat
public moi je pense qu'il faut avoir une
position un peu constante
ou bien on veut régler les choses
pacifiquement par le débat c'est
d'ailleurs ce que propose camélia
jordana ou bien on joue sur deux
tableaux comme vous faites et moi je
trouve sympa pas très sérieux
camélia jordana elle le dit avec seymour
c'est des mots forts c'est vrai mais
vous savez c'est l'article 15 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789 qui dit la société a le
droit de demander compte à tout agent
public de son administration et donc de
jeu camélia jordana estime qu'elle est
dans une situation que le pays dans une
situation qui n'est pas normale et elle
demande des comptes à un corps de la
fonction publique et la police nationale
qui aujourd'hui se dévoie parfois dans
certaines opérations de police
évidemment pas dans tout d'ailleurs
personne n'a dit de moi je me permets de
vous couper mais effectivement le monde
sacré ce que à kruth personnel tout de
même vous trouvez qu'il n'y ait pas
aller un petit peu fort camélia jordana
c'est quand même pas rien d'évoquer un
massacre je vais apprendre ce que c'est
non c'est pas rien mais vous savez je
pense que c'est à la hauteur de son
ressenti en vérité ces s'émousser pas
les miens mais c'est ses mots et j'ai
envie rogge a condamné ce que je trouve
ce que je trouve étonnant quand même
dans cette histoire c'est que vous avez
une citoyenne qui vous fait part de son
malaise qui vous le fait part de manière
honnête de son malaise vis-à-vis de de
la police nationale qui dit il ya un
problème et qui se retrouve notamment de
la faute d'un syndicat de police
au box des accusés c'est ça qui n'est
pas normal je vous le dis et je vous le
redis
si on veut que la situation se dénoue il
faut qu'un débat on peut pas mettre une
chape de plomb sur une impression sur
les débats de cette manière là on a le
droit de demander des comptes à la
police nationale sur la manière dont
elle fonctionne et camélia jordana est
quelqu'un qui est engagée elle se bat
notamment dans le collectif pour justice
et vérité pour adama traoré
ce sont des collectifs dans lesquels
nous l'inconnue des morts suite à des
interventions et à des opérations de
police et parfois les familles par
exemple je prends le cas de la famille
this is a tramp 2011 sept ans plus tard
sa famille ne sait toujours pas comment
il est mort voyez je vous parle de
situations concrètes la base de la
théorie un peu fumeuse de situations
concrètes que vous avez des gens qui ne
savent pas pourquoi les proches leurs
proches sont décédés à la suite d'une
opération de police
si on ne peut pas dire que c'est pas
normal alors on ne peut plus rien dire
dans le pays mais dans ce cas là on
n'est plus dans une démocratie on est
dans un autre régime c'est autre chose
ou c'est la police qui n'assume plus ce
rôle je dis et je finis sur ça le rôle
de la police
c'est d'amener des citoyens qui ont
promis qu'ils ont commis un crime ou un
délit parfois c'est de les amener vers
les tribunaux d'accord si en cours de
route il y à un mort c'est que
l'opération de police ne s'est pas bien
passé alors parfois il ya des
résistances si un policier se retrouve
en face de quelqu'un qui la grèce au
pistolet et qu'il tirait alors qu'il a
un maître c'est compréhensible mais par
contre quand vous avez des gens qui
parce qu'ils courent ils courent on se
retrouve décédé à la suite d'une
opération de police dans un fourgon de
police
je suis désolé ce n'est pas normal moi
j'assume de dire que je veux que ma
police soit républicaine et qu'elles
soient au meilleur niveau d'excellence
et d'exemplarité pour le pays david
olivier reverdy votre réponse non mais
je pense que le
ce guiraud se trompe de débat pour
toutes les affaires dont il a cité il ya
les la justice qui est saisie à des
enquêtes judiciaires qui seront en cours
et ni monsieur guy ronnie madame jordana
ne sont là pour faire la justice dans ce
pays
donc soit on est républicain et on l'est
jusqu'au bout et dans ces cas là on fait
confiance aux enquêtes judiciaires comme
nous nous le faisons parce que lorsque
des policiers faute
et bien sachez qu'ils sont qu'ils sont
tous très rapidement et
administrativement sanctionné que la
justice est aussi passent aussi chez
nous et que nous pouvons être aussi
condamné au même titre que n'importe qui
donc là aussi il ne faut pas faire
justice à travers des média des médias
interposés la justice est saisie pour
les affaires dont vous avez parlé j'ai à
faire et va ouvrir d'autres affaires la
justice est saisie laissez la travailler
nous en attendant on revient sur
l'actualité qui nous concerne le les
propos de madame jordana sont
inqualifiables sont inqualifiables parce
que il déjà on parle de massacre dont
très bien au delà du mou mais ce mot
quand même relativement important même
extrêmement important et choquant mais
au-delà de ça les propos qui englobe
l'ensemble d'une corporation l'ensemble
d'une corporation sont tout à fait
inacceptables tout à fait inacceptable
aujourd'hui et madame jordana met de
l'huile sur le feu parce qu'on sait que
le climat social est tendu
le climat social est extrêmement tendue
et qu'aujourd'hui
madame jordana se perd mais se
permettait justement d'attiser et de
mettre de l'essence sur des braises
vous vous demandez jamais pourquoi le
climat est tendu
vous dites pas que c'est peut-être parce
que par exemple à une étude en 2009 1,7
et le cnrs qui l'a mené aux abords d'une
gare parisienne les individus qui sont
perçues comme noir il subit six fois
plus de contrôles que ceux perçus comme
blanc que les individus perçu comme
arabe
ils ont huit fois plus de chances d'être
contrôlés que les individus perçues
comme blanches
vous croyez que la colère sociale vient
de nulle part est évidemment dans une
situation d'injustice parce qu'il ya des
injustices
ce n'est pas que la police qui l'a créé
d'ailleurs il ya des injustices sociales
mais quand il ya une injustice mais je
ne se laisse pas faire les gens qui se
noient ils se débattent et donc il ya
des résistances c'est pour ça que cette
situation n'est même pas bénéfique pour
les policiers et c'est pour ça que moi
je déplore le fait que votre position ce
soit de dire en vérité qu'il faut paquet
de départ je pense qu'un débat ça
pourrait aussi aider les policiers dans
leurs conditions de travail
parce que quand les gens ont confiance
dans la peau
ils coopèrent quand ils ont peur de la
police ils ne coopèrent pas c'est
quelque chose qui me semble simple a
rappelé et je rappelle que la cour de
cassation a jugé en 2007 que les
contrôles discriminatoires constituer
une faute lourde commise par l'état
c'est donc il ya un problème est que
même la justice dont vous parlez le
reconnaît et que quand il ya un problème
et que ça n'est pas résolu par des
pratiques conformes à la dignité des
gens bah oui il ya des résistances que
je déplore derrière standard faute
messieurs mais je voulais avant de faire
poursuivre ce débat je voulais vous
montrer quelques chiffres les résultats
d'un sondage ifop paru en janvier 2020
regarder ce tempo qui va s'afficher à la
question que vous inspire spontanément
la police de la confiance pour seulement
43% des français contre 53 % il ya vingt
ans une chute dont considérable
l'inquiétude est un sentiment qui gagne
également nos concitoyens on passe de 14
à 20 % en vingt ans david olivier
reverdy
est ce que ces chiffres il vous
interroge justement que vous en parlez
entre vous entre collègues il ya une
grande incompréhension finalement un
grand malentendu comment vous vous le
l'expliqué dans l'histoire en fait c'est
que aujourd'hui on voit la société et
plus en plus tendues et de plus en plus
difficile d'un point de vue social d'un
point de vue économique est aujourd'hui
une certaine partie de la population
refuse l'ordre de la république refuse
d'appliquer les lois de la république
aujourd'hui nous sommes là nous sommes
une police républicaine
n'en déplaise à madame jordana nous
sommes une police républicaine
lorsqu'il s'agissait de gilet jaune que
les gens soient de couleurs soient
français soit de n'importe quelle
origine
c'était pas notre sujet on était là pour
faire respecter la loi et empêcher des
exactions empêcher dû empêcher du mieux
possible de ce qu'on pouvait faire que
des commerces soient cassés que des
individus soit violente et c'était là
aussi notre métier quand on fait du
maintien de l'ordre ça se fait pas avec
des roses et des pâquerettes le maintien
de l'ordre
aussi quand on a des gens qui sont
allées de boules de pétanque de
cocktails molotov d'acide d'acide
chlorhydrique parce que mes collègues
ont reçu des jets d'acide chlorhydrique
des bouteilles d'acide chlorhydrique oui
monsieur gayraud c'est aussi la réalité
si aussi la réalité qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui
donc là aussi effectivement si vous
voyez que par le bull la lorgnette de
certaines violences qui pourraient avoir
lieu
ces violences
les prend sur des vidéos si généralement
des morceaux qui sont pas pris dans leur
contexte en l'ensemble et la justice la
justice qui se saisit des bandes
généralement rétablit le droit rétablit
le droit de l'intervention
parce que quand on parle sachez aussi
que la police monsieur guy roux la
police à à à l'exercice de la violence
légitime donc de la force légitime
c'est le code pénal qui nous lie qui
nous le lui autorise tandis que les
violences illégitimes faites par des
citoyens sont répréhensibles par la loi
mais alors vous pouvez vous faudra que
vous n'expliquez alors dans ce cas là
qu'est ce qui est légitime quand un
homme comme jérôme rodriguez sans
manifestation puisque vous parlez des
gilet jaune qui est un manifestant
totalement pacifique personnalisé
légitime ça est-ce que cet autre homme
vous savez il ya une enquête du monde
qui montrent que le tir de balistique
n'était pas approprié qui personnel en
pleine manifestation alors qu'il était
en train de discuter avec ses amis
c'est légitime ça vous voyez moi j'ai
pas une approche purement juridique de
la chose parce que si on fait comme ça
alors la société c'est juste un livre de
droit qu'on lit tous comme une bible
c'est pas ça la vérité il y a dans
l'aide dans le nôtre pays ce qui est
légitime
et puis ce qui est supportable parce que
ce n'est pas normal vous avez des gens
aujourd'hui qui sont placés dans des
situations pas normale dans le pays
quand vous êtes contrôlés beaucoup plus
que les autres parce que vous êtes noir
ou arabe parfois avec des contrôles
discriminatoires parfois même humiliant
parfois même c'est moussa tes papiers
parce que les vérités les policiers
connaissent le prénom de la personne
dont on connaît son identité mais lui
faut pas même un contrôle d'identité
eh bien ça n'est pas normal de la même
manière qu'un cas manifestants quand
bien même la durée 01 même nom à perdre
sa main il doit aller peut-être devant
les tribunaux mais le rôle de la police
de l'année devant les tribunaux pas de
rendre elle-même justice voyez c'est ça
je pense que vous avez oublié dans la
conception de votre police ne rend pas
justice le suggèrent les tribunaux et de
pour qu'ils fassent eux la justice pas
vous merci messieurs merci d'avoir été
avec moi et d'avoir accepté en tout cas
un débat courtois ce soir après ses
propos chocs de la chanteuse camélia
jordana rester avec nous dans quelques
instants
retour sur le déconfinement en europe
alors que paris doit être annoncé cette
semaine sa phase 2 du les confinements
les autres capitales européennes
poursuivent leur levée progressive des
restrictions puis nous partirons en
amérique latine qui subit de plein fouet
la pandémie
au continent et le nouvel épicentre du
coc vide 19
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons on est dans une
espèce de déni collectif on ne veut pas
croire ce qu'on sait et scientifique
parle quand même de la sixième
extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
y'a d'autres experts qui contestent nos
mesures dans 96 personnes non non c'est
pas vrai il ya des climats tous et non
ce n'est pas il y en a pas il ya des
gens qui ne sont pas des chercheurs qui
parlent que la presse met en avant parce
que il faut que du débat le ya plus de
débat aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun
débat ce changement climatique
on va faire un vrai par une catastrophe
ou 20 vers une vraie catastrophe et on
est incapable d'en prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimiste tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et les demis y en
n'a pas d'ennemi l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 merci nous rejoint ainsi la france
entame aujourd'hui sa troisième semaine
de déconfinement l'allemagne veut
prolonger ces règles de distanciation
jusqu'au 5 juillet motif la pandémie
coronavirus pourrais je cite repartir
très vite en l'absence de précautions
mesures envisagées maintenir une
distance d'au moins 1,5 mètre entre les
personnes et interdire de se réunir à
plus de 10 ou plus de deux familles dans
le même temps ce lundi marque une
nouvelle étape déconfinement en europe
en italie en espagne ou encore en grèce
tour d'horizon
[Musique]
je veux profiter de cette occasion pour
dire que les terrasses que j'ai visité
aujourd'hui toutes les personnes qui
travaillent sont très conscientes de
suivre absolument tous les protocoles
elles ont été formées pour savoir
quelles sont les précautions à les laver
mes quatre mois cependant même si elles
savent comment nous traiter la
responsabilité individuelle va être un
facteur très important
l'année dernière à peu près à la même
époque
nous avons eu des touristes nous étions
bons dès maintenant nous vivons une
autre réalité
bien sûr la crise économique va être
mondial mais nous les grecs nous avons
passé la dernière décennie à nous
occuper des sauvetages donc la crise qui
nous attend va être bien pire
[Musique]
comment
les terrasses des bars qui rouvre donc à
barcelone aujourd'hui des précisions sur
place avec leslie sigle à barcelone et
madrid ont commencé leur déconfinement
aujourd'hui les deux plus grandes villes
du pays sont entrés dans la phase une du
plan de déconfinement prévu par le
gouvernement espagnol
et ce sont deux grands assouplissement
qui ont commencé aujourd'hui
tout d'abord l'ouverture des terrasses
des bars restaurants et clubs de plage à
50% de leurs capacités d'accueil légal
et en laissant bien de mètres entre
chaque table l'autre nouveauté du jour
ce sont aussi les réunions jusqu'à 10
personnes qui sont autorisés dans la
sphère publique comme privée en
respectant les distances sociales et les
gestes barrière le gouvernement
également prévu d'autres mesures pour
les prochaines semaines le championnat
de football reprendra dès le 8 juin en
respectant aussi les règles de sécurité
et l'autre grande nouvelle très attendue
c'est l'ouverture des frontières dès le
mois de juillet l'espagne a besoin du
tourisme clamé pedro sanchez samedi
dernier il a invité les touristes
étrangers à venir d'ores et déjà est à
réserver leurs vacances pour le mois de
juillet et du coup dans les faits la
quarantaine obligatoire de 14 jours ne
sera plus imposée à partir du 1er
juillet et pour évoquer ces pays qui
lève les restrictions en ordre dispersé
nous sommes en direct avec l'autre
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous alors c'est la
pression des milieux économiques et des
entreprises plus blanche maison qui
dicte la réouverture au sein de ces pays
où est facile de réserve quand même
puisque les gouvernements au début de
l'épidémie s'était engagé à donner la
priorité à la protection des vies
humaines
et ça reste bien entendu toujours le cas
bien sûr les milieux économiques
souhaite que l'activité reprenne et on
pourrait dire en schématisant un petit
peu que les gouvernements chaque
gouvernement est pris entre deux feux
celui du pouvoir médical qui est très
prudent et qui dit ne déconfit n'est pas
parce qu'il pourrait y avoir une
deuxième phase une sorte de tsunami on
ne sait jamais et puis les milieux
économiques qui craignent la
multiplication des faillites et un
chômage de masse et qui finalement 10 si
on continue comme ça il y aura plus que
les chômeurs à confiner donc les
gouvernements sont amenés à faire la
part des choses
d'ailleurs en tenant compte également de
leur opinion publique
parce que les opinions publiques se
manifeste et notamment vont à se
manifester dans les sondages et dans les
élections et dans les actions
naturellement régulière alors la
situation est différente suivant les
pays
bien sûr pour deux pays voisins au sud
de la france l'italie et l'espagne
il n'est pas question de rater la saison
touristique
tout simplement parce que le tourisme
représente entre 13 et 15% de leur
richesse nationale de leur pnb et par
conséquent il y aura certainement des
pertes mais il est pas pensable de
perdre 15 % du pnb pour la grèce et
c'est beaucoup plus puisque c'est près
de 30%
et là encore c'est la raison pour
laquelle ces pays ont réouvert leurs
plages l'an restaurant leur hôtel leur
café et ceci va va continuer
naturellement en respectant les
les gestes barrières et en respectant la
distanciation physique pour l'allemagne
c'est un peu différent notre autre
voisin puisque la chancelière a essayé
de prolonger le confinement
par souci de sécurité et puis c'est un
petit peu heurtée aux aux ministres
présidents des différents länder qui
avec les entreprises voulait rouvrir il
fallait absolument ouvrir l'économie et
il se trouve qu'en allemagne pays
fédéral ce sont les länder qui ont le
plus de pouvoirs en matière de santé ya
donc il fallait faire un compromis est
finalement l'allemagne avec une certaine
prudence euros ses frontières et comme
ça a été dit tout à l'heure à votre
sujet le gouvernement français doit
annoncer jeudi prochain ce que sera la
phase suivante à partir du 2 juin et
l'on verra ses hôtels et restaurants
sont ouverts en tout cas en zone verte
alors chaque état avance on constate en
ordre dispersé cela peut-il provoquer
selon vous un retard dans la
restauration du marché unique
bah oui le marché unique
il existe toujours puisque les produits
circulent tout à fait librement et
notamment dans la zone euro bien entendu
avec la monnaie unique que les services
dématérialisés
circulent aussi tout à fait librement et
que le problème ne se pose que pour les
personnes et en effet il faudra à
l'avenir probablement des comptes et que
ce sera possible
rétablir la libre circulation des
personnes est actuellement des
négociations sont en cours des
négociations bilatérales que les pays
des gosses y en deux par deux pour
respecter la réciprocité les pays que
vous avez cités tout à l'heure pour des
raisons d'ouverture au tourisme vont
lever les restrictions au 1er juillet
est bien là la france les bras cerrell
ses propres restrictions vis-à-vis des
ressortissants de ces pays
à la même date il y aura donc une
réciprocité et je crois que le marché
unique de cette phase on retrouvera sa
réalité avec ses quatre libertés
dans quelques mois alors l'argent mis
sur la table par chaque pays l'argent
mis sur la table par l'europe dans son
ensemble ces mesures seront elles
suffisantes
écoutez elles ont le mérite d'exister
d'abord les états membres dans l'urgence
pris des mesures et on a entendu ce
matin le ministre des finances français
cité une enveloppe globale de 750
milliards d'euros qui a déjà été mise
sur la table si l'on additionne toutes
les mesures qui ont été prises au plan
national
alors maintenant au plan européen et
bien au plan européen
nous attendons une proposition de la
commission qui doit intervenir dans
normalement dans deux jours
elle inclura probablement tout ou partie
de la proposition franco allemand la
proposition faite par la chancelière
merkel et par le président de la
république française qui porte sur 500
milliards d'euros avec un mécanisme très
innovateur qui consiste à autoriser
l'union européenne en l'occurrence la
commission à faire un emprunt sur les
marchés financiers à inclure le montant
de cet emprunt dont le budget de l'union
européenne et à faire en sorte que avec
ces fonds et bien les régions et les
secteurs les plus impactés par la crise
du corona virus puisse toucher des
subventions pas les prêts pas des prêts
ce sont des dotations budgétaires et
ultérieurement lorsque l'emprunt sera
arrivé à maturité
l'empreinte 500 milliards d'euros eh
bien ce sont les états membres qui
rembourseront probablement avec la clé
budgétaire qui rembourseront c'est cet
emprunt là dessus évidemment il ya cinq
étapes que l'on appelle frugaux
notamment l'autriche les pays bas la
suède et le danemark qui ne sont pas
d'accord pour deux raisons église nous
ne voulons pas augmenter le budget de
l'union européenne
les raisons et deuxième raison sur le
plan de la technique financière est un
petit peu curieux de transformer des
emprunts en dons et par conséquent nous
voulons distille que cela l'emprunt
servent à faire des des prêts aux
régions et aux secteurs les plus
affectés
il est probable que les etam en trouvant
un compromis peut-être qu'il faudra à
isoler la partie résultant de cet
emprunt communautaire dans le budget
peut-être faudra-t-il faire un budget
bis peut-être faudra-t-il faire des
compromis
j'imagine que dans la proposition de la
commission certains pour promises sont
déjà esquissé notamment avec un volet
près donc emprunter près et avec
peut-être une enveloppe qui montera au
total jusqu'à 1000 milliards d'euros ce
qui s'ajoute aux 540 milliards d'euros
déjà décidée par les mines et des
finances de l'union européenne en avril
et puis par ailleurs comme vous le savez
la banque centrale européenne a décidé
de faire des achats d'obligations
publiques et privées et que ces montants
sont tout à fait considérable puisqu'il
s'agit d'un montant de 750 milliards
d'euros pour l'année 2020
alors est-ce que ça suffira personne
n'en sait rien mais il faut d'abord se
mettre d'accord sur l'utilisation de ces
moyens de ces instruments et notamment
sur la proposition de la commission qui
va arriver mercredi soir et puis ensuite
on verra bien je pense que s'il faut
ajouter des moyens supplémentaires
les pouvoirs publics nationaux et
européens
le ferons merci claude blanchemaison
d'avoir été
avec nous si les états unis ont
longtemps été considéré comme le foyer
mondial de la pandémie la situation
s'aggrave en amérique latine qualifié de
nouvelles épices en parle oms depuis
vendredi le continent subit à son tour
de plein fouet les ravages du
coronavirus grégoire douce et pour les
explications le moment le plus
douloureux de la pandémie
ce sont les mots d'andré ce manuel lopez
obrador président du mexique deuxième
pays le plus touché en amérique latine
et dans les caraïbes une région du monde
dans laquelle la barre des quarante
mille morts a été franchi ce dimanche
d'après les données officielles des
gouvernements
dans ce contexte ces scènes par est
ahurissante
le président brésilien jaillir ball
sonar au nom masqué en plein bain de
foule dans les rues de la capitale
brasilia
lors d'une manifestation de ses soutiens
nous sommes ici pour nous battre pour le
futur de nos enfants
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous voyez
des familles entières avec le drapeau
vert et jaune se battre pour leur pays
pendant ce temps des tombes sont
creusées par centaines dans le plus
grand cimetière du pays à sao paulo
chez le voisin argentin les rues restent
quasiment déserte
le chef de l'état alberto fernandes se
montrent plus prudents annonçant dès
samedi que la quarantaine durera autant
de temps qu'il le faudra
nous allons étendre la période
d'isolation social jusqu'au 7 juin
inclus
et nous allons continuer de travailler
tous ensemble comme nous l'avons fait
jusqu'ici
nous gouvernons des hommes et des femmes
et qui vivent dans un endroit se répand
un virus dont personne ne sait où il est
personne ne sait qui l'a comment on peut
le stopper et comment on peut le guérir
la quarantaine durera le temps
nécessaire pour que les argentins soit
en bonne santé et qu'il ne meure pas
en colombie l'armée a été déployée par
endroits pour freiner la propagation du
virus
c'est le cas ici à laetitia localité de
la partie amazonienne du pays une zone
frontalière avec le brésil et le pérou
autre nation parmi les plus touchées du
continent et le pérou qui compte cent
vingt mille infections et 3500 lors
selon l'université john hopkins une
crise sanitaire avec de grandes
conséquences sur le système éducatif du
pays médias qui fuit depuis le début de
la pandémie de covile 19 il se démène
dans ce que l'on pourrait appeler un
marathon quotidien ces enfants issus de
ce village isolé se déplace en direction
d'une montagne
leur objectif capter un signal radio
pour suivre des cours sans accès à
internet ni au réseau
ils sont dans l'obligation de marcher
près de 15 kilomètres dans des
conditions souvent difficiles
nos enfants ne peuvent pas apprendre ils
n'apprennent pas il n'y a pas de signal
internet
pas de signal de téléphones portables
nous n'avons rien nous devons marcher
deux à trois heures par jour car les
petits enfants ne marche pas comme les
adultes
pour ces raisons nous n'arrivons pas à
une heure exacte alors que les horaires
sont également donnés dans les stations
à des heures exactes à ce moment là nous
devons calculé à 7h30 ou 8h nous devons
quitter la maison pour arriver sur la
colline notre problème avec les
étudiants et qu'il n'y a pas de
communication à partir des téléphones
portables et pas de réseau à partir de
la radio et d'internet
deux à trois heures de marche afin
d'atteindre les 4000 mètres d'altitude
nécessaire pour capter ces fameux cours
à distance sous la pression de
l'épidémie de coronavirus le
gouvernement péruvien fermer ces
établissements scolaires le 12 mars dans
la foulée les autorités ont élaboré un
programme diffusé à la télévision
intitulé j'apprends à la maison le
ministère de l'éducation aurait acheté
plus de 840 milles tablette pour
permettre aux élèves venant des régions
rurales le suivre les programmes
scolaires
l'objectif de l'exécutif favoriser
l'accès des cours sur internet
chose impossible dans le village de kata
théorie au début du mois de mai le chef
d'état péruvien entendez miser un
maximum sur les cours à distance
il est absolument clair qu à court et
moyen terme les cours ne se feront pas
sur place mais à distance les étudiants
du primaire et du secondaire supérieur
technique et universitaire devront
suivre des cours à distance au pérou la
crise scolaire n'est pas l'unique
problème du pays l'économie péruvienne
reste paralysée depuis le début de la
pandémie
le président a prévenu que les
conséquences pourraient être très
importantes dans les mois à venir et
pour parler de la situation en amérique
latine nous sommes avec sergio coronado
ex député des français de l'étranger
justement d'amérique latine et des
caraïbes des caraïbes
bonsoir sergio coronado merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
l'amérique latine s'est depuis peu en
selon l oms le nouvel épicentre de cette
épidémie est ce que vous qui connaissez
parfaitement la région on pouvait s'y
attendre on pouvait en effet s'attendre
on a eu l'impression en effet que
l'amérique latine et est peu concernée
il y à un mois et demi mais tous les
pronostics toutes et tous les
diagnostics laisser penser en effet que
l'épidémie allait progresser et nous
n'avons pas atteint d'ailleurs en fait
ni ni l'éthique ni les plateaux namek
latine on voit que depuis quinze jours
les contaminations et les dessins ont
considérablement augmenté et des pays
comme le brésil le pérou ont connu des
augmentations est extrêmement
inquiétante en effet et puis il ya
également la situation du continent en
fait avec des systèmes publics très
délabré système de santé privé pour pour
parler globalement puisque l'amérique
latine était un laboratoire néolibérale
dans les années 90 est donc une faible
capacité en fait sanitaires
pour accueillir pour appeler à
accueillir les malades et puis il ya
également même lorsque des mesures de
confinement ont été prises une grande
difficulté à pouvoir les faire respecter
parce que l'augmentation des cas a lieu
dans des pays confiné en fait l'élément
de l'informalité en fait dans la
population active est un des facteurs
d'explication vous avez des gens qui ont
besoin de sortir pour manger et il y a
eu également des hésitations extrêmement
grande parmi les différentes les
différents dirigeants latino américains
à l'arrivée du virus sur le continent
vous avez montré le cas du brésil qui
est le plus emblématique avec un
président brésilien dias bolson ados qui
minimise en fait la gravité du virus et
qui prend encore il ya quelques jours
des bains de foule à brasilia mais il ya
eu également des mesures un peu
incohérente common perreault qui a
laissé ouvert les grands marchés tout ce
qu'ils sont devenus en fait des foyers
de contamination on voit quand vous
parlez ces images justement ne savons
pas l'eau paulo avec des enterrements
voilà en masse entre guillemets comment
peut-on être aussi corneau sceptiques
comme les reer bol sonar ou est-ce que
c'est du cynisme parce que c'est un déni
pour justement favoriser un certain pays
d'en assumer notamment la suède
favoriser tout simplement l'économie
faut pas oublier qui est bien le bol
sauna non cette impression d'extrême
droite
une sorte de représentant du 36 mhz en
amérique latine avec des
caractéristiques très local certes mais
rappelez-vous les premières réactions du
président north america qui minimisait
finalement la gravité la gravité de la
pandémie
donc vous avez en effet un personnage
politique qui même aujourd'hui n'a pas
conscience ou ne veut pas prendre
conscience de la gravité de ce virus et
des mesures qu'il faudrait prendre les
mesures nécessaires pour pour l'endiguer
heureusement au brésil il ya eu quand
même
les gouverneurs qui ont mis en place
dans la plupart des états des mesures de
confinement eux mais il faut le dire la
manière de se comporter de ronaldo ça
oubliez aussi à une logique en fait à
une exaltation de sa base électorale
vous avez vu également dernièrement aux
états unis des manifestations pro trunk
qui dénonçaient les mesures de
confinement vous avez à peu près ce même
type de phénomène aujourd'hui également
au brésil
aujourd'hui que doit-on craindre pour
ces pays d'amérique latine qui sont
parfois instable qui était déjà en
difficulté avant cette crise ça va être
un soulèvement des manifestations ont
peut-être encore davantage de colère
sociale
alors vous avez une situation économique
qui s'aggrave et certainement le
continent vit une crise économique
depuis le début des années 2000 2010
pardon qui est une conséquence de la
crise de 2007 qui a dévasté en partie
les économies nationales
vous aurez certainement dans des pays où
il existe de très grandes inégalités
sociales des phénomènes de révolte parce
que on a des situations de fin au brésil
ou de malnutrition vous avez eu à
santiago dernièrement des pillages vous
allez en colombie des quartiers entiers
à bogota par exemple avec des chiffons
rouges aux fenêtres dans les
appartements de familles qui n'ont pas
de quoi se nourrir et en même temps
est-ce qu'il faut également voir c'est
que des tendances autoritaires se met en
place avec une militarisation du pouvoir
au brésil 1-2 ministre de la santé qui
ont démissionné qui ont été remplacés
paramilitaires la mise en place au chili
qui avait été surpris par un grand mot
social avant la pandémie la mise en
place d'un couvre-feu de 18h à 6h du
matin qui n'avait qui n'obéissent à
aucune logique sanitaire mais qui
permettait en effet de mater toute
tentative de manifestation et révolte
sociale en colombie vous avez
des leaders sociaux des syndicalistes
qui continuent d'être assassiné donc en
effet on peut craindre un affrontement
une mobilisation en raison des
problématiques sociales de la pauvreté
qui va qui va croître considérablement
et puis un durcissement des pouvoirs en
place
ma dernière question sergio coronado
vous lisiez à une instabilité une crise
économique qui datent pas d'hier qui
s'aggrave évidemment avec cette crise
est ce que ça laisse présager le monde
d'après est un vrai changement pour le
coup de deux systèmes dans ces pays
selon vous de fait il ya une prise de
conscience sur la fragilité des états
latino américains il n'y a pas
d'équivalent sur les comptes sur le
continent d'état social enfin les filets
de sécurité en cas en cas de crise ou en
cas de pandémie on le voit sont
inexistants il ya cependant des pays qui
se débrouillent mieux que d'autres vous
avez par exemple une forme de contre
exemple avec le costa rica qui connaît
peu de décès et qui nous tient à s'est
formidablement la propagation du virus
parce que c'est à l'état qui a abandonné
il ya très longtemps
l'armée et qui a orienté en fait les
investissements militaires vers la santé
et l'éducation est aujourd'hui s'en sort
plutôt bien vous avez également en
argentine des des expérimentations
sociales tout à fait intéressante avec
la mise en place d'une sorte de revenu
d'urgence qui est une prime pour les
plus précaires ou l'idée de dan et impôt
sur la richesse
je crois en effet que c'est des
questions qui vont être dans le débat
public mais rien ne permet aujourd'hui
de dire que le monde apprenne à la
cathine sera meilleur que ce que le
continent vite aujourd'hui
merci faire giocondo ex député des
français de l'étranger d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france et c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans quelques minutes à 22h
rester avec mon frère
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
est ce qu'on sait combien d'enfants sont
victimes de ces violences et qui sont
concernés par ces drames qui se déroule
dans le huis clos familial pendant la
période actuelle il est difficile de
dire précisément combien d'enfants sont
concernés car en fait on a très peu de
visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le dise
ils redisent là le problème c'est que
dans le cas du confinement il ya plus
cet entourage et tout se fait à distance
ce qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude un porte
plutôt sur ce que vous voyons pas la
partie l'énergie de la sbm en fait parce
que les très difficile pour les enfants
malgré tout d'aller le même
et dans ce cas là on n'entend rien ça se
fait totalement dans le silence
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et l'infante allant de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant et on refermait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision à vraisemblable
pour vous ça dépend quelle valeur on
attribuait la mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
morales un débat éthique
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques et sur ces sujets sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon interprétation
dans la crise ducobu 19
c'est toute une chaîne décisionnelle
médicales administratives et politiques
et responsables du fiasco
alors que l' oms recommandait le port du
masque par les populations la parole
publique a longtemps menti sur sa
nécessité pour ne pas avouer la triste
absence du top 10 la décision de
confinement s'imposait compte-tenu du
manque de matériel permettant d'autres
solutions mais en freinant l'hécatombe
on pénalise l'économie l'état ne pourra
plus être l'état providence que nous
avons que bora bora et et cimetière de
certaines espérances en pensant que le
progrès faisait de nous des hommes dieu
et que les technocrates avec les du
monde demain des conséquences de la
crise oblige à repenser nos modèles la
découverte du télétravail l'intérêt de
consommer des produits locaux le besoin
de solidarité vont faire évoluer une
population qui a découvert qu'elle était
mortel
[Musique]
on va parler évidemment de l'impact
économique de cette pandémie est ce que
tous les pays africains vont être
impactés continu envers voit vraiment
une de ses pires années de ses tantes
dernière même si les conséquences sont
différentes selon les pays
nous avons là une situation où pour
sauver les économies africaines il va
falloir créer de l'activité il faut de
l'argent pour pouvoir se tirer
d'affaires pendant cette année 73
millions de personnes touchées quand
même par une crise alimentaire dans
quelle mesure cette pandémie du colis de
19 risque d'aggraver les choses ça c'est
la troisième crise la voir là sanitaire
qui est là et la crise économique nous
allons avoir une crise de sécurité
alimentaire
[Musique]
hausse significative des salaires et
changements dans le quotidien à
l'hôpital dans les tout prochains mois
déclaration d'edouard philippe qui vient
d'ouvrir le ségur de la santé une
visioconférence avec 300 acteurs du
milieu hospitalier pour répondre aux
préoccupations des soignants éprouvé par
la crise du coc vides et alors que paris
doit s'avancer jodie les arbitrages à la
face de lui des confinement les autres
capitales européennes poursuivent leur
levée progressive des restrictions en
italie les salles de sport reprenne les
terrasses ou en espagne et en belgique
et a fait face à de nombreuses plaintes
si l'europe se des consignes l'amérique
latine subi l de plein fouet la pandémie
est le continent le nouvel épicentre
ducobu 19 selon l'organisation mondiale
de la santé principaux pays impacté dans
la région le brésil un cycle pérou
système éducatif pâti de la crise
sanitaire
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt francs
si vous nous rejoignez coup d'envoi du
ségur de la santé après plus de deux
mois de crise sanitaire l'exécutif et
300 personnalités du monde hospitalier
se met au chevet d'un milieu
professionnel en difficulté rémunération
organisation est temps de travail elle
les précisions avec thomas boni le
premier ministre a ouvert officiellement
ce ségur de la santé en promettant du
changement dans le quotidien des
personnels hospitaliers certain niveau
de rémunération ne sont pas à la hauteur
de l'engagement voilà pour une des
déclarations du premier ministre qui a
en quelque sorte poser les bases de
réflexion pour cette concertation qui
sont qui s'ouvre donc aujourd'hui parmi
ces pistes de réflexion il ya la
question de la reconnaissance des
soignants le premier ministre promet une
revalorisation significative des
salaires le temps de travail la question
du temps de travail n'est pas une
question taboue a également a déclaré
edouard philippe parmi les autres pistes
avancées par le premier ministre celle
de l'investissement et du financement
des hôpitaux ou encore une nouvelle
organisation du système de santé au
niveau territorial voilà qui devrait
servir de point de départ pour cette
discussion qui réunit 300 participants
au tour du ministre de la santé et du
premier ministre
de leur côté le personnel soignant
attend des actes concrets un certain
nombre d'entre eux étaient présents à
quelques mètres du ministère de la santé
pour faire entendre leurs revendications
des revendications qu'ils portent
parfois depuis des années je propose de
les écouter étant donné que tu es quand
même pas mal de temps déjà qu'on demande
et que
ne serait-ce que là avec le
sous-effectif on est tous plus tôt on
attend de voir
on attend de voir un moment donné il
faut qu'ils embauchent aussi et donc
pour embaucher il va falloir augmenter
les grilles salariales c'est clair parce
que ça fait déjà des années et des
années qu'on n'arrive pas à embaucher
il nous manque 800 900 infirmière sur la
paix sont ça c'est inadmissible
du fait de salaires trop bas tout
simplement les eaux est partout où elles
ne viennent pas ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose oui c'est quand
même 100 milles plus de 100000 dit qu'on
était fermé depuis 15 ans et ça c'est
pas normal et donc on l'a vu là
justement sur la gestion de la crise où
il nous a manqué des lits il a fallu
rouvrir des services qui étaient fermés
mais en avec une grosse grosse vétusté
est donc là il a fallu rouvrir ça et
faire dans l'urgence on l'a fait il n'y
a pas de souci c'est notre job c'est ce
que je dis on en compte dix vous êtes
des héros vous êtes non on n'est pas des
héros enfin moi je me considère pas
comme un héros jeu on est payé pour
faire un job on a fait notre job m'a
lancé des conditions qu'on l'a fait
qu'ils sont complètement déplorable mais
c'est pour ça ou si on est là il faut
pas qu'il use le gouvernement attendus
sur des réponses concrètes donc par le
personnel hospitalier la concertation de
ce ségur de la santé devrait durer entre
sept et huit semaines
à l'issue de ces discussions un plan
devrait être présenté par le
gouvernement et on verra à ce moment là
s'il répond aux attentes du personnel
hospitalier particulièrement éprouvés
par la crise du collègue 19 ans stéphane
augé et chef du service de réanimation
pédiatrique à l'hôpital robert debré les
aides soignantes trois revendications
majeures
la première revendication très forte
c'est effectivement une augmentation
salariale est un geste fort tout de
suite avant la mise en route de
négociations par branches en fonction
des statuts ça ce sont nos collègues des
syndicats qui les porteront mais on veut
un geste tout de suite de reconnaissance
des personnels
la deuxième c'est un moratoire immédiat
sur l'arrêt des fermetures de lits je
pense que là aussi le coville a
parfaitement démontré on a manqué de
lits dans certaines régions faute
d'organisation il faut arrêter de fermer
des lits redonner la main aux régions et
aux territoires pour réfléchir à quel
endroit on peut en ré ouvrir en ré
ouvrir plus voir arrêter d'en ouvrir
dans certains autres ça ça doit être
une décision locale en tous les cas
prises avec l'ensemble des personnels et
puis il faut troisième geste fort sur la
gouvernance qu'on n'a jamais réussi à
obtenir pour une seule raison c'est que
le gouvernement ne voulait pas investir
dans l'hôpital public à la hauteur des
besoins
s'il décide de le faire on va regarder
qu'il donne aussi la main au personnel
et aux usagers pour arriver réellement à
gouverner correctement l'hôpital public
et parallèlement à ce ségur de la santé
manifestation cet après-midi de
soignants devant l'hôpital henri mondor
à créteil dans le val-de-marne ont fait
le point sur place avec notre reporter
mona hamou dès lors le personnel
soignant s'est mobilisée juste devant
l'hôpital henri mondor à créteil pour
porter haut et fort leurs revendications
à savoir une revalorisation des salaires
et les meilleures conditions de travail
il faut le dire elle ses revendications
et sont au coeur de la mobilisation des
hôpitaux depuis des années des gens se
souvient juste avant le confinement de
ces grandes manifestations de la part
des urgentistes des médecins et des
infirmiers cette journée n'a pas été
choisie au hasard puisque c'est
aujourd'hui qu'olivier vers ans avait
entamé les négociations avec les
professionnels de santé pour améliorer
les conditions de travail
on a pu parler à quelques soignants ou
encore médecins et demandé leur avis je
vous propose de les écouter on a porté
aux efforts de revendications
d'accord les personnels ici présents
arrive à se libérer pour descendre et
pourquoi je dis il arrive à se libérer
parce qu on est tellement influent
tendue que eux mêmes pour descendre dans
la rue et pouvoir exprimer leurs
revendications et nord et leur colère on
n'y arrive pas on arrivait au bout de
notre système
concrètement on est à saturation dans
les hôpitaux dans aux urgences on le
voit très bien nos collègues ont
manifesté à ont fait grève
l'année dernière
et en fait les urgences et la première
entrée c'est la porte d'entrée de
l'hôpital comme on dit mais sauf que le
problème que qu'à nos collègues des
urgences il est le reflet en fait du
problème hospitalier en général j'ai
attendu le concret qu'on nous donne le
concret des paroles des paroles c'est
bien beau de plus de temps nos salaires
ont été gelés depuis je ne sais combien
d'années ça n'avance pas
ça n'avance pas donc non on attend du
concret vous l'avez entendu le personnel
soignant attend beaucoup de ces
nouvelles négociations avec le
gouvernement emmanuel macron lui avait
reconnu le 15 mai une erreur de
stratégie dans les réformes engagées en
2017 dans le domaine de la santé
ces réformes elles sont donc très
attendues et à la mi-juillet des
nouvelles annonces sont prévues les
taureaux keane les études se suivent et
ne se ressemblent pas suite à une étude
très critique publié par the lancet ce
vendredi l' oms indique ce soir avoir
suspendu temporairement les essais
cliniques avec ce médicament qu'elle
mène avec ses partenaires dans plusieurs
pays par mesure de précaution écouter
les analyses de violaines guérin il me
gist et de laurent alexandre médecins et
essayiste
je pense qu'il ya d'autres études
également qui ont conforté dans le monde
les résultats de l'équipe du professeur
out il ya des pays et on le voir les
pays qui ont prescrit ce qu'ils ont
préconisé son protocole sans forcément
faire les études puisque comme on est un
peu en temps de guerre quelque part des
pays ont donné l'aval pour ce protocole
et on voit très bien que qu'il ya moins
de décès et que comme des choses se sont
mieux placés
les données de l'étude du lancet sont
inquiétantes il y a pas mal d'études
pourrait même dire une avalanche de
données inquiétantes récemment les
données du british medical journal ne
sont pas bonnes non plus qui doivent
nous inciter à la prudence
mais il n'est pas possible d'affirmer ce
soir que le protocole du procès raul tu
tues davantage que le placebo
on ne peut pas dire ça ce soir mais
certains le craignent certains le
craignent suffisamment pour que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé est
interrompu son essai enfin la partie de
son essai qui concerne hydroxy
chloroquine pour vérifier qu'on
n'observe pas un avec un comité spécial
qui va regarder quel est l'état de la
mortalité chez les gens qui sont sous
hydroxy chloroquine dans l'essai qui est
organisée sous l'égide de de l'om est du
côté économique à partir du 1er juin
l'état n'assurera plus la prise en
charge complète du chômage partiel mis
en place en début de confinement
déclarations du ministre l'économie
dans ces saisons qu'elle sera je suis
raisonnable et salariés ne perdront rien
ce sont les employeurs qui vont devoir
payer un peu plus a précisé le patron de
bercy les entreprises assumant 15% du
coup dès le 1er juin selon le ministère
du travail
en revanche pour les secteurs qui ne
reprendront pas leur activité au 1er
juin l'intégralité du chômage partiel
sera maintenu et pour l'économiste henri
sterdyniak le chômage partiel a permis
d'éviter de nombreuses pertes d'emplois
mais il est encore trop tôt pour mettre
fin à ses aides selon lui d'abord on
avait mis en place un système qui était
extrêmement généreux puisque l'état
prenait en charge en totalité le salaire
de personnes qui restaient chez eux
ce système a très bien fonctionné
puisque la france n'a pas connu de
fortes eu jusqu'à présent de forte
poussée du chômage
comme on a pu le voir ou aux états unis
c'est un système qui naturellement doit
petit à petit être mis en extension
parce que il faut que les gens
retournent au travail
la grande question c'est de savoir est
ce que on ne met pas en extinction trop
tôt sachant qu' il reste encore beaucoup
d'entre eux près de 2,2 cas où les
salariés ne peuvent pas venir travailler
pour des raisons de transport pour des
raisons d'enfants et de l'horizon de
garde d'enfants et là c'est peut-être un
peu tôt
1 direction maintenant la guadeloupe où
le réseau de distribution d'eau est
largement défaillant une situation qui
s'est aggravée avec la crise sanitaire
plus de détails et becqueter aux combes
et livan sepric ainsi que cette même
base basit
ne pas avoir accès à l'eau potable en
france en 2020 une situation
inimaginable qui pourtant celle dans
laquelle se trouvent de nombreux
guadeloupéens
les habitants de l'île compte
régulièrement des coupures d'eau qui
peuvent durer plusieurs semaines voire
plusieurs mois provoquant une profonde
exaspération
bah oui on est en colère parce qu'on
paye quand même des factures d'eau
franchement et c'est pas top quoi parce
qu on a besoin d'eau dans la vie
courante a besoin d'autres dans le
contexte de la crise sanitaire actuelle
ces difficultés d'approvisionnement pose
de nombreuses questions au chu de
guadeloupe comme dans la plupart des
établissements de santé
on demande aux patients de venir avec
leurs propres ou tous témoignent de la
complexité de respecter les gestes
barrière dans ces conditions disque faut
se laver les mains faut avoir une bonne
hygiène pour mon fait pour faire sans
eau surtout les personnes âgées tout ça
ils peuvent pas transporter de l'eau
c'est pas tout en étant dit je n'avais
que vous transportez pour eux donc ils
sont plus atteint ce nombre depuis de
nombreuses années le réseau de
distribution d'eau insulaire est
régulièrement décriée en raison de sa
trop grande vétusté dans le viseur la
gestion chaotique du syndicat
intercommunal d'alimentation en eau et
d'assainissement de la guadeloupe qui
gère le réseau depuis près de 50 ans son
ancien directeur hamilius hernandez a
été condamné l'an passé à trois ans de
prison dont deux de sursis et 150 mille
euros d'amendé pour détournement de
fonds et favoritisme dans l'attribution
des marchés publics le syndicat est
régulièrement accusé par la classe
politique locale de détourner l'argent
destiné à entretenir le réseau
le problème c'est que nous avons un
passif mafieux scrupuleux qui a on va
dire ils ont détonné environ un milliard
d'euros c'est à dire que les
consommateurs les usagers de l'eau sur
leur facture d'eau ont été ponctionnés
chaque mois
dumas chaque fois qu'a bonne facture il
avait ponctionné la partie qui devait
réparer les canalisations et cette
partie au lieu de servir à la réparation
des canalisations
cette partie a été détourné malgré un
rapport gouvernemental sur la question
publiée en mai 2010huit dénonçant une
crise de l'eau systémique sur l'île
et le lancement de nombreux chantiers
afin de réhabiliter le réseau de
distribution de nombreux guadeloupéens
n'ont toujours pas accès à l'eau potable
signe de la gravité de la situation le
préfet de guadeloupe
philippe gustin a profité de l'état
d'urgence pour réquisitionner la filiale
locale de suez est une société suisse
afin de cartographier les fuites et de
réduire les pertes
un travail titanesque le coût des
travaux pour la réhabilitation de
l'ensemble du système de distribution
d'eau est estimé à près d'un milliard
d'euros
l'état belge visé par des plaintes pour
sa gestion de la crise sanitaire et une
quarantaine de personnes estiment que
les mesures de confinement imposé était
trop restrictive
argument avancé des contraintes qui
irait à l'encontre de plusieurs articles
de la convention européenne des droits
de l'homme principal ministères visés
celui de l'intérieur dont le locataire
est terre de crem qui déclarent attendre
une situation citation à comparaître
écoutez l un des avocats des plaignants
fou qui me raconte qu'il le voit mais
c'est à l'apport du wellness sont très
faibles
il démonte un problème mais quand on va
dans le détail on va voir quelle tous
les chiffres ils sont où les élites et
les est pas là mais ce sont en effet pas
certaines pas sûr et à la fin il faut du
recueil on sait presque rien de secret
russe
il y en a pris des mesures qui nous on
peut douter l'efficacité mais aussi on
peut douter si ces mesures sont bien
conformes aux droits de l'homme aux
techniques qui sont prévus dans dans le
traité si la france entame aujourd'hui
sa troisième semaine de déconfinement
l'allemagne veut prolonger ces règles de
distanciation jusqu'au 5 juillet motif
la pandémie pourrait je suis reparti
retrait vite en l'absence de précautions
j'envisage et maintenir une distance
d'au moins 1 m 50 entre les personnes et
interdire de se réunir à plus de 10
ils sont plus de deux familles dans le
même temps ce lundi marque une nouvelle
étape du déconfinement l'europe et
illustrations en italie en espagne ou
encore en grèce
[Musique]
je veux profiter de cette occasion pour
dire que les terrasses que j'ai visité
aujourd'hui à toutes les personnes qui
travaillent sont très conscientes de
suivre absolument tous les protocoles
elles ont été formées pour savoir
quelles sont les précautions à l'ailé
mais quatre mois cependant même si elles
savent comment on est traité la
responsabilité individuelle va être un
facteur très important
et l'année dernière à peu près à la même
époque
nous avons eu des touristes nous étions
bons dès maintenant nous vivons une
autre réalité
bien sûr la crise économique doit être
mondiale mais nous les grecs nous avons
passé la dernière décennie à nous
occuper des sauvetages donc la crise qui
nous attend va être bien pire
[Musique]
quand
les terrasses des bars qui rouvre
également à barcelone aujourd'hui les
précisions avec leslie sangla sur place
barcelone et madrid ont commencé leur
déconfinement aujourd'hui les deux plus
grandes villes du pays sont entrés dans
la phase une du plan 2d continent prévu
par le gouvernement espagnol
et ce sont deux grands assouplissement
qui ont commencé aujourd'hui
tout d'abord l'ouverture des terrasses
des bars restaurants et clubs de plage à
50% de leurs capacités d'accueil légal
et en laissant bien de mètres entre
chaque table l'autre nouveauté du jour
ce sont aussi les réunions jusqu'à 10
personnes qui sont autorisés dans la
sphère publique comme privée en
respectant les distances sociales et les
gestes barrière le gouvernement
également prévu d'autres mesures pour
les prochaines semaines le championnat
de football reprendra dès le 8 juin en
respectant aussi les règles de sécurité
et l'autre grande nouvelle très attendue
c'est l'ouverture des frontières dès le
mois de juillet l'espagne a besoin du
tourisme clamé pedro sanchez samedi
dernier il a invité les touristes
étrangers à venir d'ores et déjà est à
réserver leurs vacances pour le mois de
juillet et du coup dans les faits la
quarantaine obligatoire de 14 jours ne
sera plus imposée à partir du 1er
juillet répond claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales les
états membres de l'europe ont dû prendre
des mesures drastiques pour relancer
leur économie
évidemment on dans l'urgence pris des
mesures et on a entendu ce matin le
ministre des finances français cité une
enveloppe globale de 750 milliards
d'euros qui a déjà été mis sur la table
si l'on additionne toutes les mesures
qui ont été prises au plan national
alors maintenant au plan européen et
bien au plan européen
nous attendons une proposition de la
commission qui doit intervenir devant
normalement dans deux jours
elle inclura probablement tout ou partie
de la proposition franco allemande
la proposition faite par la chancelière
merkel et par le président de la
république française
qui porte sur 500 milliards d'euros avec
un mécanisme très innovateur qui
consiste à autoriser l'union européenne
en l'occurrence la commission à faire un
emprunt sur les marchés financiers à
inclure le montant de cet emprunt dans
le budget de l'union européenne et à
faire en sorte que avec ces fonds et
bien les régions et les secteurs les
plus impactés par la crise du corona
virus puisse toucher des subventions pas
des prêts pas des prêts ce sont des
dotations budgétaires et ultérieurement
lorsque l'emprunt sera arrivé à maturité
mais emprunt de 500 milliards d'euros
eh bien ce sont les états membres qui
rembourseront probablement avec la clé
budgétaire qui rembourseront c'est cet
emprunt est si les états unis ont
longtemps été considéré comme le foyer
mondial de la pandémie la situation
s'aggrave en amérique latine qualifié de
nouvel épicentre par l'om est depuis
vendredi le continent subit à son tour
de plein fouet les ravages de
coronavirus grégoire doux c'est le
moment le plus douloureux de la pandémie
ce sont les mots d'andré ce manuel lopez
obrador président du mexique deuxième
pays le plus touché en amérique latine
et dans les caraïbes une région du monde
dans laquelle la barre des quarante
mille morts a été franchi ce dimanche
d'après les données officielles des
gouvernements
dans ce contexte ces scènes par est
ahurissante
le président brésilien jaillir ball
sonar au nom masqué en plein bain de
foule dans les rues de la capitale
brasilia
lors d'une manifestation de ses soutiens
nous sommes ici pour nous battre pour le
futur de nos enfants
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous voyez
des familles entières avec le drapeau
vert et jaune se battre pour leur pays
pendant ce temps des tombes sont
creusées par centaines dans le plus
grand cimetière du pays à sao paulo
chez le voisin argentin les rues restent
quasiment déserte
le chef de l'état alberto fernandes se
montrent plus prudents annonçant dès
samedi que la quarantaine durera autant
de temps qu'il le faudra
nous allons étendre la période
d'isolation social jusqu'au 7 juin
inclus
et nous allons continuer de travailler
tous ensemble comme nous l'avons fait
jusqu'ici
nous gouvernons des hommes et des femmes
et qui vivent dans un endroit où se
répand un virus dont personne ne sait où
il est personne ne sait qui l'a comment
on peut le stopper et comment on peut le
guérir la quarantaine durera le temps
nécessaire pour que les argentins soit
en bonne santé et qu'ils ne meurent pas
en colombie l'armée a été déployée par
endroits pour freiner la propagation du
virus
c'est le cas ici à laetitia localité de
la partie amazonienne du pays une zone
frontalière avec le brésil et le pérou
autre nation parmi les plus touchées du
continent est le pérou qui compte cent
vingt mille infections et 3500 morts
selon l'université john hopkins une
crise sanitaire avec de grands
conséquences sur le système éducatif du
pib baisse qui fuit depuis le début de
la pandémie de covile 19 il se démène
dans ce que l'on pourrait appeler un
marathon quotidien ces enfants issus de
ce village isolé se déplace en direction
d'une montagne
leur objectif capter un signal radio
pour suivre des cours sans accès à
internet ni au réseau
ils sont dans l'obligation de marcher
près de 15 kilomètres dans des
conditions souvent difficiles
nos enfants ne peuvent pas apprendre ils
n'apprennent pas il n'y a pas de signal
internet
pas de signal de téléphones portables
nous n'avons rien nous devons marcher
deux à trois heures par jour car les
petits enfants ne marche pas comme les
adultes
pour ces raisons nous n'arrivons pas à
une heure exacte alors que les horaires
sont également donnés dans les stations
à des heures exactes à ce moment là nous
devons calculé à 7h30 ou 8h nous devons
quitter la maison pour arriver sur la
colline notre problème avec les
étudiants et qu'il n'y a pas de
communication à partir des téléphones
portables et pas de réseau à partir de
la radio et d'internet est deux à trois
heures de marche afin d'atteindre les
4000 mètres d'altitude nécessaire pour
capter ces fameux cours à distance sous
la pression de l'épidémie de coronavirus
le gouvernement péruvien a fermé ses
établissements scolaires le 12 mars dans
la foulée les autorités ont élaboré un
programme diffusé à la télévision
intitulé j'apprends à la maison
le ministère de l'éducation aurait
acheté plus de 840 milles tablette pour
permettre aux élèves venant des régions
rurales le suivre les programmes
scolaires
l'objectif de l'exécutif favoriser
l'accès des cours sur internet
chose impossible dans le village de kata
tir au riz au début du mois de mai le
chef d'état péruvien temps des mises et
un maximum sur les corps à distance il
est absolument clair qu à court et moyen
terme les cours ne se feront pas sur
place mais à distance les étudiants du
primaire et du secondaire supérieur
technique et universitaire devront
suivre des cours à distance au pérou la
crise scolaire n'est pas l'unique
problème du pays l'économie péruvienne
reste paralysée depuis le début de la
pandémie
le président a prévenu que les
conséquences pourraient être très
importantes dans les mois à venir et
pour ceinture ornée d'un ex député des
français de l'étranger les pays
d'amérique latine ont du mal à faire
appliquer les mesures de confinement
on voit que depuis quinze jours les
contaminations et les décès ont
considérablement augmenté et des pays
comme le brésil le
oh on est connu des augmentations est
extrêmement inquiétante en effet et puis
il ya également la situation du
continent en fait avec des systèmes
publics très délabré système de santé
privé pour pour parler globalement
puisque l'amérique latine a été un
laboratoire néolibérale dans les années
90 est donc une scène de capacité en
fait sanitaires pour accueillir pour
appeler accueillir les malades et puis
il ya également même lorsque des mesures
de confinement ont été prises une grande
difficulté à pouvoir les faire respecter
parce que l'augmentation des cas a lieu
dans des pays confiné en fait l'élément
de l'informalité en fait dans la
population active est un des facteurs
d'explication vous avez des gens qui ont
besoin de sortir pour manger et il y a
eu également des hésitations extrêmement
grande parmi les différentes les
différents dirigeants latino américains
à l'arrivée du virus sur le continent
vous avez montré le cas du brésil qui
est le plus emblématique avec un
président brésilien des isles bolcho
nadeau qui minimise en fait la gravité
du virus et qui prend encore il ya
quelques jours des bains de foule à
brasilia mais il ya eu également des
mesures un peu incohérente common
perreault qui a laissé ouvert les grands
marchés pour ce qu'ils sont devenus en
fait des foyers de contamination pressé
la fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir
suivi les programmes continus sur arte
france prochain journal 7 heures du
matin heure française excellente fin de
soirée à tous
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
toulepleu moins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
loïc et geoffroy de la culée sont deux
frères explorateurs animés par une
passion commune l'eau